Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I know.
What else are you posting a question?
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This episode is brought to you by teeter.
I am so thrilled to have connected with these guys because I've used teeter
products for many,
many years.
I've traveled around the country and the world with teeter products and I'm
sitting about 15 feet in my home from one of their inversion tables and we're
going to talk more about all of that.
One of my rituals is hanging and I should say not really that it's a maintenance
and performance program.
I hang not just in the morning potentially,
but particularly after a day of bearing weight,
whether that includes weight training and Jersey Gregorich world record holder
insists on this type of inversion therapy after training or just wearing heavy
backpack around a few minutes.
It goes a long way towards better sleep.
In my case,
less back pain,
neck pain,
leg pain.
It's not a panacea obviously,
but inversion therapy which uses gravity and your own body weight to decompress
the spinal relief pressure.
On the discs and surrounding nerves seems to help with a whole slew of
conditions and just as a general maintenance program,
it's one of my favorite things to do.
So what to say about that teeter?
Why teeter teeter is the best known name in inversion table since 1981 more than
3 million people have put their trust in teeter teeters.
Also the only inversion table brand that has been both safety certified by
underwriters laboratories.
That's a UL for you.
People in that industry,
you will recognize it and registered with the FDA as a class one medical device
and they're giving a very special offer just to you guys,
my listeners,
for a limited time,
you can get the teeter inversion table with bonus accessories,
which I have a bunch of again in the room next to me and a free pair of gravity
boots so that you can invert at home or take the boots with you to the gym.
So these gravity boots,
I have three separate pairs of gravity boots bought with my own monies in three
different cities that I've had for a very,
very long time because I don't want to travel with them necessarily.
They look kind of like ski boots,
but without the foot portion,
and they hook you upside down so you can take them really anywhere you want to
go to get this deal,
which is a savings of over $148 it's very specific,
so maybe it's 149 you have to go to teeter.com forward slash Tim that's
teeter.com forward slash.
Tim,
t.
E.
T.
R.
You also get free shipping,
a 60 day money back guarantee and free returns.
So why not try it out?
Remember,
you can only get the teeter inversion table with bonus accessories and a free
pair of gravity boots by going to twitter.com forward slash.
Tim
So if you're thinking to yourself,
what the hell is this thing that he's talking about?
I can't even envision it in my head.
Well,
take a look at the photos.
Go to teeter.com forward slash Tim.
Okay.
This episode is brought to you by legal zoom,
which more than 2 million Americans have used to help start their businesses.
Past guests even such as well,
wordpress lead developer,
CEO of Automattic,
Matt Mullenweg now valued it more than a billion dollars,
have used legal zoom to help with their business needs,
specifically in his case to form his company.
But legal zoom isn't just for launching your business.
Their services include everything from helping you to manage changing tax laws,
reviewing contracts,
creating Ndas,
nondisclosure agreements,
important stuff,
handling lease agreements,
and assisting with really any other legal challenge,
hurdle,
inconvenience that typically takes time and effort away from running your
business.
The best part is that you won't get charged by the hour because legal zoom isn't
a law firm,
so they won't be running the clock up and spinning circles just to raise your
bill.
Instead,
they just ask you to pay one low upfront price for whatever it is that you're
looking to get all a carte style.
So visit legal zoom.com and check out their business section for all of their
services and if you want special savings,
that's the terminology in the copy that they suggest.
I don't know what the special savings is folks,
but it's titillating.
If you want special savings,
enter Promo Code Tim Tim at checkout capital t,
lowercase.
I am again,
take a peek legal zoom.com and enter Promo Code Tim.
Hello,
am I dialing?
Literally Mark [inaudible].
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to deconstruct world class performers,
to tease out the habits,
routines,
experiences,
life lessons,
frameworks,
etc. That you can hopefully apply to your own lives.
My guest today is someone I've known for quite a few years now.
She's incredible.
I HSA Tyler,
that is a I,
s h a t y l e r on Twitter,
Instagram,
Vimeo and beyond.
She is an award winning director,
actor,
comedian,
bestselling author,
podcaster,
and activist.
She does just about everything and if you've enjoyed my episodes with,
for instance,
Brandon Stanton,
Debbie Millman or Adam Robinson,
among others,
you will love this one.
Whether you do creative work,
want to be too complex to categorize,
want to overcome rejection and be the odds despite the fears and insecurities.
We all have this,
we'll have something for you.
I should voice is super spy.
Lanacane on Fx is Emmy Award winning animated Comedy Series Archer,
which one for back to back television critic's choice awards.
She is a regular on the hit CBS show.
Criminal minds now in its 13th season for which she has also directed should
continues to host the CWS hit Improv show whose line is it anyway and she's
launching a line of bottled cocktail.
She courage and stone in summer of 2018 and take a breath,
sit back.
That's not all.
Let me get a little bit more in just to give you a taste.
And men,
this doesn't even capture a small fraction,
but here we go.
I actually,
it was a coast for seven seasons of CBS is Emmy winning daytime show at the
talk,
which she departed in September,
2017 to focus more on acting and directing.
She's also very well remembered for her character arc on friends where she was
the first African American to have a longstanding role on the show.
Her feature film debut,
the thriller access all caps a x I s premier 2017 and one of the outstanding
achievement in feature filmmaking ward at the 2017 Newport beach film festival
and then had a theatrical run at arclight Hollywood,
landmark NYC and Drafthouse in my home of Austin,
Texas.
Alamo Drafthouse,
so much fun.
A San Francisco native where I also spent a very,
very long time.
I should graduated from Dartmouth College with a degree in government and
environmental policy,
which you might not have known.
She is an avid gamer and passionate advocate and a occasional adversary of the
gaming community and her voice can be heard in video games like halo,
reach gears of war three and watchdogs.
I,
she has a bourbon and hardrock fan,
a snowboarder and a Psi Phi obsessive and we cover so much ground in this
episode.
It's very wide ranging.
She's hilarious.
And,
uh,
I,
he really,
really,
really enjoyed the twists and turns in this particular podcast episode.
So without further ado,
please enjoy and you can find more to enjoy at.
I should tyler.com of course,
the namesake of Ayesha tyler.com.
I used to Tyler,
Ayesha,
welcome to the show.
Hello,
and thank you.
I'm super excited to be here.
You know,
this is,
this is our,
this is our way.
It's a very long home in a way for us.
It is.
And you are partially to blame slash credit for me having a podcast in the first
place,
because I recall when you interviewed me for girl on Guy Podcast in San
Francisco,
uh,
at my place and I had so much fun speaking with you and fielding some fantastic
questions,
one of which I'm going to bring up and then we'll,
we'll backpedal.
Okay.
But this one,
the question will not be surprising to you,
I don't think,
and I'm going to ask you to bring it up,
but the,
uh,
the conversation that we had in part contributed to me deciding to take a break
from writing books,
which had completely burned me out and in turn helped birth the show.
So thank you for helping to send me on this path because it's become one of the
most gratifying and fascinating things I could possibly imagine doing.
So thank you for that.
That's so thrilling to and really,
really gratifying.
Um,
uh,
yeah,
I mean that's a,
it's amazing.
I think podcasts are wonderful and terrible beast,
but like really satisfying even even when they're like punishingly difficult to
manage,
they're still so satisfying.
So I'm really happy.
I'm happy that you're enjoying it and you have,
uh,
we're not going to get into this right now,
although we can you have a,
a book titled Self Inflicted Wounds,
subtitle,
heartwarming tales of epic humiliation.
And can you maybe repeat or,
or even paraphrase the question that you would always ask guests on your show?
Oh,
absolutely.
I mean,
th th that came,
that the name for that book came from this part of my show,
self inflicted wounds,
which is what,
you know,
tell me a story about something that's gone wrong in your life that's your own
fault.
Like a,
you know,
you can't blame anyone else,
not your,
not your ex,
not the bullies in your school,
not the man,
you know,
you did it to yourself.
And it was,
it was,
it was really a way of initiating a conversation about risk and failure because
I feel like,
um,
people see people who are successful and assume that a part of that success or
the reason that the successes that they haven't made any mistakes and they
haven't failed,
that they've got a charmed life in some way or are they figure some kind of
formula out.
And you know,
the,
the most successful people are people who not,
don't just manage risk,
but engage in risk and,
and,
and court failure actively.
Um,
and I,
so I always love to,
you know,
have people listening see that some of that they admire and that they think is
really accomplished is really shit the bed
at some point in their lives maybe multiple times.
Because I just think it's,
it's instructive.
I think people don't start because they're afraid they're going to fail.
And,
uh,
and,
and there's just no way around,
you know,
the,
the path to success is through failure.
You just can't get around it.
So there are so many different directions I could go with this and I want to,
to go way back as a,
maybe like sort of a montage flashback that we could have as a visual overlay as
you're,
as you're saying some of these things.
Uh,
and that is to your dad.
And I've in the process of doing homework,
uh,
read about your dad's favorite saying or,
or question that he would ask.
And I was hoping you could,
you could explain this or share this with people who are listening because I
think it's kind of amazing.
Yeah.
Um,
well,
I was raised,
you know,
my parents divorced when I was 10,
and,
um,
and my father,
my parents,
you know,
I always joke that like,
it's only rich people that can afford to fight about custody.
You know what I mean?
Poor people just do whatever they have to do to like manage.
And my parents,
neither of them could really afford to kids and also neither of them could
afford to pay child support.
So each of them just took one
of us.
And,
um,
I was older,
so I went with my father and he was like,
you know,
which,
which one can wash itself.
And then that was the one that he took it with me.
Um,
and he,
you know,
my father is the king of the,
like the,
the very terse and pointed motivational speech.
Um,
so I would leave for school in the morning.
And,
uh,
we lived in,
I grew up in San Francisco and,
uh,
and at one point we lived upstairs and a Victoria.
And so I'd go down these very steep stairs and she'd lean over the railing and
he'd go,
whose day is it?
I'd have to say,
it's my day.
And then he'd say,
what are you going to do?
And I'd have to say,
grab it by the balls.
I didn't want,
are you going to do what I'd have to say and twist and twist.
Um,
but,
you know,
it's funny because it was like my dad was just,
he was such a great dad.
He was a really engaged guy.
But you know,
I mean it was a,
c was a single father and relatively young.
So maybe there,
there were a few boundaries of propriety that he danced along.
But,
um,
but he just encouraged me,
you know,
um,
it just encouraged me to be aggressive,
you know,
he was one of those,
I think it's very hard for,
for single parents,
period.
And I think it's very hard for fathers and daughters because,
you know,
I just think if you're a dad,
the world just looks like,
you know,
a field of broken glass and potholes and molten lava.
And then you've got this little kitten and you're just like so terrified to put
the kitten down.
So either big grip very tightly.
Or in my father's case they throw you up in the air,
you know,
and expect that they've given you the skills to land.
And that was definitely
strategy.
Now you mentioned the,
the,
the divorce,
which I have read was amicable and it ended up,
ended up resulting in you going with your father and you have one sibling,
a younger sister,
and she stayed,
she stayed with your mom.
What was that hard or,
or did it not even occur to you to be hard because it just is what it was or
was,
were,
was that difficult and,
and did you have constant contact or what was the dynamic like?
You know,
it's interesting because I think it was more the second for me.
Like it just was what was happening.
And,
and I,
I don't ever remember,
I don't ever remember struggling in any grand way with the way that things were
going.
I,
you know,
and look,
maybe that's my nature.
I do my,
I know my parents worked very hard to be loving and available to both of us and
I had like lots of access to my mother and I talked to her all the time and I
call her for advice and when she got to kind of be the fun mom or the advice
mom,
you know,
she didn't have to discipline me and she could just be the person who was there
when I needed like emotional support.
Um,
I,
I do know that like,
one of the things that resulted in,
at least when we were younger was my sister and I,
but we weren't super close.
But,
but I,
you know,
lots of siblings aren't super close in their kids,
whether they're living in the same house or not.
They're fighting and they're competitive.
But I,
but as we got older,
I became like wildly protective of my sister.
And,
um,
and,
uh,
like my relationship with her is so intensely loving and affectionate now.
And I don't know,
maybe if we lived in the same house driving each other,
you know,
nuts all the time.
We wouldn't be as close as we are now.
I mean,
we spent the formative years of our lives living in different houses,
but we like the same stuff and,
and we care about the same things and,
and our,
our connections really deep.
So I,
you know,
I can't,
I don't ever remember kind of sitting up at night feeling any kind of agony
about the fact that my parents were divorcing.
I did watch them try very hard to stay together.
Like I do remember that when they got a divorce,
I was like,
they really gave it a shot.
You know,
I could see that.
They really like,
you know,
I just,
they would break up and they'd get back together and they'd break up and they
get back together and I'd ride,
I'd like walking on them and they'd be making out on the couch.
I was like,
they are really giving us to go.
So
when they decide it was over,
I was like,
okay.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't ever,
I don't ever remember it being like a point of agony.
He just thinks changed,
you know,
and,
and maybe as a result I tolerate change better than I would otherwise.
Or maybe I even crave change.
I don't know.
Has it been your demeanor to generally look at things through a positive lens
like that where you would frame what other people might try to frame is a very
difficult agonizing experience into something that was,
or at least as framed as something positive that you benefited from or,
or have you had more of the time,
a tendency to frame things negatively?
That's a really good question and I think about that a lot cause I think that
my,
my attitude or my point of view about things is half biochemistry and,
and half,
uh,
like child rearing.
Um,
my father is just like a,
like a preternaturally optimistic person.
Like it's,
it's extraordinary.
I always make this joke that if my father's house was on fire,
he would like get a stick and marshmallows.
Like he just cannot be deterred.
You don't worry if you can't,
I've never seen it.
You know,
he's just never down.
And I,
and so I think that I inherited that and maybe it's attitude.
No,
I think I just probably make the chemicals in my brain that kind of keep me
typically upbeat,
you know what I mean?
And,
and I think it's important because I think a lot of times when people,
when people are,
or if they have a hard time seeing the world positively or they're struggling
with depression,
people like we just need to look at it a different way.
But I think that I probably just make more of the chemicals that enabled me to,
to be optimistic.
I just,
you know,
I've never,
I've never really been depressed,
but my father also was just a walk it off that he just did not feel sorry for
me.
And you know,
and I was not allowed to feel sorry for myself.
And so when things went wrong,
and this is definitely sustained until I was an adult,
I just,
I just get up and I keep going.
And that was because of,
you know,
my father was raised,
he lost,
his father wouldn't,
he was very,
very young.
He's raised by a single mother,
you know,
like tumble down Pittsburgh with the very few opportunities for a black man at
that time.
And he just never felt sorry for himself.
He was just like,
look,
I can complain about the situation or I could just keep moving.
And,
and I,
so I think I've been nurtured in that way as well,
which is the world is unfair.
Uh,
they're,
you know,
it's shot through with assholes.
I still have to get up in the morning and make a life for myself.
Um,
and so it's probably a combination of those two things.
Were you,
would you say good at following his advice of not only grabbing life by the
balls but twisting,
which is a whole new level?
Those are two really like,
yeah,
like you can gently grab balls.
You can't really gently grab and twist balls that's hosting.
Is that,
that's an elevated,
yes.
That's embarrassed form of aggression.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know,
like it's hard to say like,
oh,
I a nail on it,
you know,
that's not how I feel.
But I do think that like that attitude of like,
you know,
just kind of go and I wrote about it a lot about it in my book.
Like the idea that like my parents raised me to be brave and,
and in some ways maybe to brave,
but the result has been like a relentlessness.
Um,
and in the pursuit of the things that are important to me.
And that's not the same as like I'm winning.
I don't really think about things that way,
but it's just if I want to do something that I do it and I don't really worry
too much about whether it's going to go my way,
not because I expect it to go my way,
but because it doesn't matter if it goes my way because it's the engagement
that's most meaningful to me.
It's the effort.
I got it.
So the bay engagement,
you mean sort of the dog [inaudible] persistence?
Yeah.
That you're developing
the engagement in,
in,
in your,
in your personal goals.
Like if I want to do something,
whatever,
I don't know,
let's pick something really innocuous.
Like,
if I want to like hike everyday for a month or if I want to start meditating,
if I don't dial it,
it's not as important to me as,
as,
as not looking back and saying to myself,
Oh,
I should have done it.
Like it's,
it's the,
it's the doing for me.
That is the reward.
And then sometimes things go away and sometimes they don't.
But the thing I find most upsetting his regret.
Yeah.
Because that's,
that's something I have control over in the sense of like if you didn't do it,
you have nobody to blame but yourself,
you know.
Right.
You can always attempt.
You can't predetermine
yes,
yes.
Yeah.
You can't predetermine the outcome,
but you can predetermine the effort because the effort is,
is the only thing that you own.
You can't own results.
You can only own,
you can only own initiative.
Do you recall any,
you mentioned your dad being a,
walk it off dad,
I want to explore that a little bit.
Do you remember any,
uh,
while you were still under his watch or not,
early disappointments or self inflicted wounds and,
and,
and how your dad responded or,
yeah.
Um,
well this isn't,
this is,
this isn't exactly a good example of a disappointment,
but it's,
it's a perfect example of his attitude.
I am,
I was going to camp,
I was,
I must have been about eight or nine,
nine,
I'll say nine.
And,
um,
that was going to like,
you know,
Jujitsu camp.
Uh,
and this was still a,
this was still during the free range parenting era where you just got up in the
morning and you left at home and you came back later and that stuff was your
responsibility.
You see eight or nine.
And then Jujitsu camp,
I was,
I was really into martial arts and I was a kid.
So it's making me think of the movie.
Hannah,
we're,
this Eric Bana trades his daughter to be a super killer.
I wish I was that good.
All right.
First thing that was not,
what am I strong?
Stronger.
Um,
but,
uh,
but as I,
as I pointed out,
it wasn't the result that was important.
It was just the effort.
So I would ride my bike to camp every day,
um,
and right at home and it was a good,
you know,
it was a good ride.
It's like a five mile right to camp.
And,
um,
I fell one day coming down like a pill,
you know,
kind of,
I dunno if you know,
this is,
this was like no helmets.
This was a long time ago.
I'm very old,
like,
you don't know how much,
just like Willy Nilly your backpack on and you know,
you're not signaling.
And,
uh,
I fell and I hurt my arm very badly.
And,
uh,
I went,
I can't remember,
but I contacted my dad and he's like,
oh,
but I'm not going to come get you.
I can't leave work.
You have to get home on your own.
Um,
and,
and I,
so I rode my bike back from camp,
you know,
like another three,
four miles and my arm was broken.
It was definitely broken.
I broken my arm.
Um,
and I got home and my dad was like,
ah,
your arms not broken.
I mean,
you see this needs to stop complaining.
You know,
it was a sore.
The next day I woke up,
it was like black and swollen and I had to like,
you know,
like lifted off the pillow and he finally took me to the doctor and it was
absolutely like,
come,
come up,
fracture the bone,
hadn't come through the skin,
but it was a multiple fracture.
Um,
but my,
I,
I think at the time it felt cruel,
but I think my dad's larger attitude was like,
no one is coming to save you.
You have to save yourself.
You have to find a way every single day to save yourself.
And,
and as a result,
I think that,
you know,
as an adult,
it just don't spend a lot of time like a anguishing over what other,
what's been done to me,
you know?
Um,
and I was fine.
I did ride my bike home and my arm was broken,
but I still got home on my bike.
And then the next I got a super dope cast.
I think we just raised like these,
I mean I know I sound like everybody's mom,
but I just feel like we're just,
we're curating young people's experiences so aggressively nowadays that they
just don't have any way to discover things about themselves.
They don't develop,
not just self sufficiency but like a curiosity about themselves and their
abilities and what they can tolerate and what they can do if left alone cause
they're just never left alone.
And I was just,
I had
a lot of time alone when I was a kid and,
and uh,
and I still really like being alone as an adult.
Right.
And also it strikes me that if you're so protective of your child and your
child's ego that you effectively disallow them to fail or engage with risk that
the,
the delta,
the difference between their actual competencies and abilities for self
preservation and their overinflated sense of their capabilities is actually a
huge disservice.
Absolutely.
And,
and their sense of like,
you need to know what it feels like to fail and then what,
what,
what comes next?
BecauseW is what comes next is what did I learn?
How can I just,
how do I pivot?
How do I move forward?
And just,
most people don't develop those mental skills.
They just,
they're crushed by failure.
And it's,
it's just an unavoidable element of life.
And,
and,
you know,
there's so many people that I know who's out of real.
I mean,
you know,
genuine love parents.
Like I just don't want to see my kid in pain,
but like,
how are you going to,
how do people move through the,
the,
the planet?
How do the people move through life without pain?
That's,
that's a,
that's a false theory.
It can't be done.
It just cannot be done.
And so people just become incapacitated the first minute they hit a,
any kind of a speed bump in their lives and,
uh,
they just don't know how they don't,
how to navigate disappointment.
Uh,
whereas I was just deeply disappointed throughout my childhood,
so I know exactly what it feels like.
I guess like a maximum,
like,
oh that didn't go my way.
Moving on,
you know.
Well yeah,
it's,
it makes me conjure in my mind the image of this,
this increasing sort of amplitude of pain consequence over your life from like
childhood to adulthood where the consequences grow potentially greater and
greater.
We're in the beginning,
like when you're a child,
you're basically engaging with,
with pain,
and I shouldn't say Pam,
but failure in many cases,
not all cases but many cases where you're,
you're effectively in one of those like birthday party,
blow up sumo suits,
do you what I'm talking about.
And it's like all right you so you can,
you can sort of engage with failure that way and if you get knocked on your ass
it doesn't,
there aren't really real consequences.
And then you get,
you get to high school,
college and it's like okay,
you're out of the sumo suit but you've got big kind of blow up boxing gloves on
and huge piece of headgear.
And then you then when you get out into some aspects of the real world,
it's just a bare knuckle brawl.
And so if you haven't had the chance,
permanent consequences.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
So if you haven't had the chance to get wailed in the face with the sumo suit,
you're not going to be ready for the bloat,
boxing gloves and the head gear.
And if you,
certainly,
if you don't get whacked in the face a few times doing that,
you're just going to be crippled when you get out into the real world and get
know,
drop kicked
in the face by,
by someone who doesn't follow the same rules,
uh,
and,
and crippled in that way.
You know,
and I know you've interacted with people like this in that way where you know,
when something bad happens there,
their whole monologue.
It's like,
why me?
Like,
why did this happen to me?
You don't understand what I'm going through.
It's like you're not at,
you're not special.
Everybody is experiencing the same thing.
Everybody,
everybody's heart as being broken.
Everybody isn't getting the job they want it.
Everybody isn't going to sleep with what the hot person they want.
Everybody is experiencing this same failures.
He's same injuries,
but you just don't know how to tolerate them.
You are not special.
And that's not the same as saying you have potential for being special,
you know,
you do.
There's nothing anybody's doing now that hasn't already been done at,
that won't be done in the future.
And I,
those,
those kinds of personalities drive me crazy because they just,
uh,
there's,
there's so stuck and boring.
What did,
what did you think you were going to be when you grew up?
When you were in high school or college?
Oh God.
In high school.
I,
it's so interesting cause I was like super academic and I think I was thought
I'd be an attorney.
I was really,
I was like,
you know,
I was like a big activist and organized and marched and did all that stuff.
And I was,
I was at like really like in the,
you know,
the outing club and I rock climbed and all that stuff.
So I thought I was going to be like an environmental lawyer,
um,
either an environmental lawyer and environmental engineer.
And then I got to,
and I want it,
I really wanted to go to a school that was like,
like really grounded in relationship to nature.
So I was applying to like,
you know,
Marlboro College and read and,
and Bard and these schools that were like out in the woods.
And I ended up going to Dartmouth,
which is,
you know,
in,
in New Hampshire and has this big land grant around it.
And uh,
and I thought I would be an environmental engineer and I think I just took like
the first prerequisite math course for engineering and I was like,
yeah,
okay.
It's not just not going to be,
this is not fake.
I always loved,
I always loved science,
but um,
I'm just a person of letters I guess and I didn't have the appetite for it.
It wasn't as glamorous as I thought.
I think when I took my first engineering I did,
I think I've got through the math class,
like did fine,
like I've applied myself and I got a good grade.
And then I went into my,
like,
you know,
an introduction to engineering three and it was about like building like a fecal
matter treatment plant.
And I was like,
this isn't feeling like hugging trees at all,
man.
We're just talking about poop all day.
Um,
I lost my appetite for that.
Really.
So then what,
did you just have this great access,
existential angst or did you sort of shift to something else immediately
following that?
I was always doing kind of like performing things on the side.
Like I,
I went to a high school that had a performing arts kind of like magnet or like a
pocket school within the,
the,
the regular school called the j u d mcateer school of the arts.
So I was kind of doing my regular class work and then doing like Improv and
stuff and sketch on the side.
And then I went to Dartmouth and I was doing some of the same stuff.
Like,
you know,
I wasn't one of those in infernal,
Ivy Leagues,
acapella groups that have been popularized since then by shows like glee.
And,
uh,
so it was always kind of doing that as a hobby because it just never felt like a
real job.
Um,
and I graduated and I was,
I was living in San Francisco and I was working for a conservation organization
that was like a killer.
It was like,
I got like my dream job.
It was a,
a group that purchased like blighted urban land and turned it in at the parks
and underserved neighborhoods that didn't have any outdoor space for kids to
play.
And you know,
it was like the mission was great because it was,
it wasn't just kind of conservation of contraries and sake.
It was like conservation focused on engaging underserved communities.
And it was the grooviest and I was just miserable and I just miserable because I
just,
I didn't know.
It was a really good question.
You know,
it was like,
why,
if I have my dream job in the city of my birth,
uh,
why am I so unhappy?
And I'm,
and I just did a lot of soul searching and I realized it was because I,
for the first time in my life,
I wasn't doing anything created.
I wasn't performing.
And so,
um,
I,
I'm,
I'm a problem.
I'm a problem solver.
I'm a matrix builder.
I was like,
well,
how can I solve this problem right now?
And,
um,
I looked at all the ways that I could get on stage and stand up.
Comedy was the only thing I didn't need to know anyone for have a,
an agent or a,
or a band or connections,
I could just do stand up right away.
And so I started studying it and watching the precursor to comedy central,
which was this network called ha of very short lift network,
uh,
and make taking notes.
And um,
then,
you know,
after a while just kind of screwed up the courage to go and do an open mic.
And then that was,
it was just transformational.
I was like,
oh,
this is what I want to do with my life.
Was the thinking immediately on how to turn performance into a career or did
you,
did you expect that you would continue doing your job and doing stand up on the
side?
Like was it a career move from when you first built the Matrix and decided on
stand up or was it,
you know what,
this is going to be great.
I'll continue doing this job and I'll scratch my creative performance itch on
the weekends with open mics.
Yeah,
it,
it's so funny because like I don't think I even realized that standup comedy was
a job.
Um,
you know,
was like a really bookish kid and I know a lot of guys will have these stories
about how they grew up,
you know,
with like Red Fox,
on vine all that they listened to hundreds of times or you know,
following,
you know,
Lenny Bruce or you know,
these idols or bill Hicks.
I just,
I didn't like,
I remember seeing live on the sunset strip when I was a kid,
but like I just saw Richard Pryor was an alien.
Like,
I don't even think like a magical person who came down to do this thing.
I just,
the idea that that was like a vocation was just not in my head.
So,
um,
I remember seeing Stanhope at Dartmouth when I was like a sophomore and coming
out of a show and being like,
like,
do you like,
do people know that this like you can go and have this feeling for an hour.
Like this is insanity.
Like I just remember like everything hurt from laughing my face and my stomach
and I just never experienced live comedy before.
So it,
it,
it didn't dove tail into like a job at first.
It was just I something I was going to do for fun.
I kept my day job 100% and I kept her a long time.
I,
I also didn't want to be like one of these kind of like miserable,
you know,
sweating standups or like gripping their,
kind of inky notebook and sleeping on their buddy's couch.
You know,
like I was in a relationship and,
and I had a job that paid great and I could make flyers for my shows at work was
like embezzling,
you know,
a copy paper,
uh,
and,
and push pins as well as aggressively as I could.
So,
uh,
I was,
and I still am of the opinion that like,
you should absolutely keep your day job,
uh,
which I know is not the most popular.
I'm a Barista.
I'm over the same opinion.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I think,
I think it gives you a freedom.
People think it traps them,
but I think it gives you this incredible freedom to just pursue art for Art's
sake and led a job,
pay for it,
and,
and do it for so long that everything you do is just for joy and,
and it changes the way that you,
it changes the way that you approached your art.
Um,
you know,
I would like get up and I'd go to work at like seven and I,
six or seven in the morning and I work until four and then I jumped in the car
and I'd drive two hours to Sacramento,
do you know,
set and I come back at midnight,
I do it all over again,
but I could do that.
And it was just purely about the experience of performing and not about whether
I was getting paid or not.
So I did that for a long time before I finally quit my job.
Now,
for those people who don't know the geography of,
of Northern California where I lived for 17 years,
and coincidentally the s the high school that you went to,
is that now the Ruth Asawa school on O'shaughnessy?
Um,
yeah.
But up to that they are at the let kind of like
the excess of [inaudible] slash Glen Canyon.
Exactly.
I literally lived for five or six years about a quarter mile from that school.
It was right there.
Not a big city.
Even though I think you,
when you feel it,
when you live there,
it feels like it.
But it's like it's an intimate right
place.
And,
and given the density of San Francisco and the fact that it is,
well,
I'm not going to go.
So I don't know if people would consider it a comedy town,
but there certainly clubs.
And
why would you go all the way to Sacramento?
Sacramento is not for those people who don't know the area.
It's not like a 10 minute drive away from San Francisco.
It's far,
always had.
San Francisco has always had a reputation for a comedy town.
Like the big comedy towns in the United States,
uh,
from comedians perspectives are San Francisco,
Chicago,
Boston,
and New York.
La is not,
I mean,
La is a company town,
but it's not a comedy town.
Um,
and San Francisco was always one of those places that people saw as like a real
crucible for kind of original comedy.
You know,
it was like where the alts comedy movement happened.
Um,
and you know,
when Mark Marin and Janeane Garofalo and these kinds of alternative comics,
Brian Plus Sane,
uh,
came out of,
and uh,
it was a comedy town,
but when I started doing comedy,
it was like the beginning of the contraction of,
of the comedy economy.
So there was a period of time when there were just hundreds of comedy clubs
everywhere and you could make a living doing standup.
He could kind of go from place to place and you could get a Gig and you could
get paid.
And I started doing standup at the beginning of the end of the comedy bubble.
So when I started doing standup,
the club community was contracting and some of the big clubs in San Francisco
are closing.
I think at one point they were maybe like five or six active clubs.
And then by the time I was working consistently,
there were only two.
And there was just a lot of competition for stage time.
And to get good at comedy,
you can't just do it like once a weekend,
you know,
you need to be on stage.
Like every night I,
it's,
it's like being a high diver or you know what,
it's literally like Malcolm Gladwell's 10,000 hours and you're not going to get
10,000 hours of standup hanging out in San Francisco.
Like you have to go everywhere and take every single opportunity to be on stage
that you can get.
So,
um,
I would drive to Sacramento,
I would drive to Fresno,
I would do these terrible,
you know,
like bar shows and in Menlo Park and Oh God,
I don't even remember some of the places.
Um,
for t Cupertino and Martinez,
I mean you would just go anywhere that you could get six minutes on stage and
then other people trying to get those same six minutes.
So it was really competitive.
I mean the co the culture where I think was pretty supportive,
like comedians were supportive of each other,
but it just,
there just wasn't enough stage time so that you just do anything and go anywhere
to get it.
So what to ask about this comedy contraction?
Uh,
we won't spend too much time on this because I don't want to take us completely
off the reservation.
But
what happened?
I mean,
it was like beanie babies,
like people were really the beanie babies.
It's like,
no call.
It isn't cool anymore.
And then all the clubs close.
W W was it just a macroeconomic downturn?
I mean,
what happened?
I think,
I think it was,
there were three factors.
One factor was just,
there was just a glut.
They're just,
you know,
it,
it for a live comedy in some ways in the seventies and eighties was kind of a
new thing.
And it's not like people had been doing stand up prior to that.
But the proliferation of standup comedians in the,
in,
in the culture really started happening at that time.
And,
uh,
what that was fueled by,
I honestly don't know,
like,
why were there so many more comics doing standup in the 70s and eighties maybe
because that was the period where there were these superstar comics,
um,
that were kind of,
you know,
I'm trying to think of who would have been really popular besides like Bill
Hicks.
And,
um,
I could see that though,
maybe it's analogous to like celebrity,
the celebrity chefs in the last 15 years.
And part of the reason why there so many more celebrity chefs because they've
started to be celebrity chefs on television.
Right?
And so if you think about that in terms of comedy,
what you,
what you see is,
oh,
that's a job.
I can make money at that.
Whereas people weren't really encountering live comedy if they didn't go to a
live comedy show.
Uh,
and so you start to see these guys on TV and you think,
and honestly,
when the,
when ha the precursor,
um,
to comedy central started,
they needed,
like they needed comics and they needed opportunities.
They needed clubs,
they needed,
they needed content.
It was a 24 hour network.
So there were,
there were some good comedians on that station and there was some really,
uh,
some really shit
really bad.
Um,
and so a lot of people watching probably thought,
well,
I can do that,
you know?
Um,
I also think about guys like,
you know,
Sam Kinison and Andrew dice clay.
There was kind of like a golden era in that time and we were seeing all those
people on TV.
Then we were seeing a lot of people that were like really subpar.
And a lot of people are thinking,
well,
if that guy can write five crappy minutes about an airplane,
I can.
Then you coupled that with this explosion in comedy clubs,
which were a relatively new phenomenon.
I mean,
when Joan Rivers was doing stand up,
she was doing standup and in strip clubs there were very few comedy clubs and
comedy was kind of a part of a Vaudeville approach.
So you'd,
you'd hire a singer and then you'd hire a comment,
but there wasn't a,
there weren't places dedicated to comedy.
So these comedy clubs opened.
It was really easy to wait way to make money because comics,
comics weren't that expensive.
And you know,
you had a two drink minimum,
people would come and they would get wasted.
You have huge margins on your boots.
So all these comedy clubs started proliferating and then they're just was just
peak.
There was just Pete clubs that it became unsustainable.
So they started to contract because of,
of market saturation.
The economy started to contract in the 80s and people could watch comedy on TV.
The proliferation of comedy on television affected people going out to see it in
a club.
So they were like kind of those three factors.
Oh,
all kind of intersecting.
Um,
and when it happened it was really aggressive.
Like I said,
I think there were maybe like five or six comedy clubs in San Francisco when I
was in high school.
And then by the time I was doing standup in my twenties,
there were two.
Wow.
So you,
you,
you would do and you know,
and they were attracting like,
you know,
like high end,
like peak talent.
So for example,
this club still there,
it's called the punchline lunch a few times.
And uh,
there was the punchline and there was cobs.
And those are still the,
the,
the only two clubs.
And maybe there's some minor clubs that have sprung up since then,
but you know,
they would book these big headliners.
So the only time you could go up if you are an amateur,
like a young comic was on a Sunday or a Wednesday and there'd be 20 other guys
trying to get on it,
you know,
as well.
And it would be wildly competitive.
Um,
and you wouldn't be getting paid,
you know,
and,
and then you'd be super anxious because you'd be like hoping,
okay,
I need to go up and I need to destroy it because I want this club owner to hire
me again so I can't go up and I can't work out.
I can't,
I can't fail in front of this guy because he won't see this.
Like,
um,
you know,
when you watch like a,
an Olympic skater during practice and they're falling,
I mean that's,
that's what practices,
four practices for like finding your weak spots and reinforcing them.
But when you're up in front of the comedy club on our new,
it's been six months that you've been trying to get all of this club and you
finally get five minutes.
It's got to be a monster,
five minutes and,
and so,
um,
there was just no way to improve.
If you can't improve,
you can't just going to say,
how do you,
how do you get in your rough drafts?
And I mean,
how do you work on the material drive to Martinez?
Oh,
I see.
So you'd write work out the kinks with
the crew at the such and such casino and God knows where Turlock fubars or
rooster t feathers or you know,
one of these other places.
Yeah.
Um,
and,
and it,
there was this,
um,
you know,
it's different than being an author or an athlete or even a musician because
there's an autonomy to comedy.
Absolutely.
But you need other people.
You,
you can't do it.
It can't just sit around your place practicing.
You know what I mean?
Like with music,
you know,
it's,
if you're sharp or flat,
you know,
if you hit all the notes,
if the tempo is right.
But with comedy,
the only way it works is in front of an audience.
Um,
and so you're very dependent on,
on stage time and that's,
it's everything.
When you're a young comic has stage time.
Do you remember your early content or what kind of,
what was your approach early on?
Uh,
do,
do you remember the first,
and maybe if I in a different way to approach this,
you can take it,
answer it however you like.
Do you remember the first time that you bombed or the f what is your first
memory that comes to mind of bombing?
Oh God,
I bombed so many times.
It's just hit all seeps together into an inky blackness.
Um,
any comic,
it tells you that ever bond is lying.
And,
and,
and again,
the only way to get funny as to bomb you.
No one ever,
no one ever gets funnier after they kill.
You know,
they just walk on that,
follow that bitches and they dropped the bike.
You know what I mean?
They go off and do shots of their friends.
I mean you really need to,
you really need to bomb and bomb.
Hard to get funny.
Um,
I remember doing this one show.
Oh God.
So there was,
there was an open mic in a laundromat,
um,
in like,
like south and market around the police station there.
So what maybe like,
you know,
eighth a mission or something like that for San Francisco.
Uh,
I think it was called brainwash.
Think the,
the
place was called brainwash and they would have this open mic in the back of this
laundromat and comics.
No,
you know,
with these open mics,
with these local open mics at,
typically there are no actual audience members in the audience.
It is just a room full of comedians waiting for you to be done so that they can
try on their material.
You know,
look,
all of them looking at their notebooks,
not listening,
not laughing,
and you're just kind of trying to gut it out and,
and,
and pause where you think the laughter might occur if you were in front of
actual human beings.
And,
um,
I just did,
I sit a set where I just,
I did not get one laugh and I remember that,
well,
not even like,
not even like a cursory titter and I remember just size.
It's just like really like,
like just a wall of silence.
And I got off.
I was even thinking about it right now.
It's so funny to me,
like I called a friend or I talked to a girlfriend,
I,
I was like,
oh my God.
Like I couldn't even call that Yvette said,
I don't know what that was,
but it was so funny to me that I didn't get a laugh.
Like I,
it was,
it,
there was this,
there was this like bulletproofness that I got from that set that just made me
impervious to anything ever going wrong in my,
in my life or career again and at every like,
even when I'm talking about it now,
it's like there's a huge smile on my face because it was so funny how,
how little,
how little I was able to elicit that of that audience.
Um,
but,
but it made it,
it made me,
it just made me so mentally strong.
Was that the immediate response that you had had or were you in the middle of
the set when you're like in the back of your mind thinking,
wow,
no one is laughing.
Was there,
did you go from like Penn,
it,
was it like the reverse of the five stages of grief?
Like what,
or did you just go straight to like,
yeah,
mother fuckers,
this is great.
Like I've just accepted,
this is going to make a great story of however many years from that on Tim
Ferriss's podcast.
Well,
one thing comedians love is,
is agony.
I mean it's way we dine out on it is definitely like our stock and trade.
So a comedian very quickly,
uh,
transitions from,
Oh my God,
this is the worst night of my life too.
this is going to make a great story that happens almost instantaneously.
Um,
so,
so we,
we have a little bit of a,
we have some armor and in that regard,
because you know,
you could just,
we could wake up like naked and shivering on the side of the road with like no
money and no phone and you know,
and not speak the local language and you'd be thinking,
okay,
well if I live this is going to make a killer story.
Uh,
so I think in the moment I just thought I had watched a couple of other people
go up and not do very well either.
I was prepared for it not going my way.
And I just thought,
I'm just,
and I think also there's a discipline to comedy that if you're not a community
you can't understand,
which is that you've got to get up and do your set.
There is,
there is no,
you don't get to tap out like tapping out as tapping out as true failure.
You know,
if you,
if you went up and you've had a bad set,
well you just need to write new jokes,
but if you go up and you give up,
that's true.
Failure for a comedian.
Um,
and,
and there,
there are some really
famous examples of this online.
Um,
I don't know if you know the comedian bill burr,
but I,
so I interviewed Belper about a year and a half ago and I played the video which
he had never seen.
Reclaimed has never seen is some real,
he has still has some psychic,
he has some,
he has some trauma.
He has.
Can you,
for people who don't know the story,
can you please describe it cause it's just
amazing,
right?
It's insane.
So he was,
he was doing like one of those big like radio,
you know those radio station concerts like the jingle ball or whatever.
And I don't remember,
it was called the weenie roast.
I think it was the weenie roast.
That's what's one of the shows at like some local station k rock eight 97 point
rock a rock,
you know,
like one of those shows and it's like,
I don't know wheezers too cool of a band.
It would be like Nickelback and you know,
some other band that sounds like nickel back and then nobody,
man you'd never heard of anyway.
And,
but they paid.
Uh,
they,
I don't know why people still do this,
but you know,
if you're a comic and someone offers you money,
you take it.
So they would hire a comic to kind of warm up the crowd,
you know,
early in the day.
And you know,
no one,
no one pays to see Nickleback and then wants to sit through 15 minutes of
standup.
You know,
everyone's drunk and on frogs and they're not even facing forward.
You know what I mean?
It's just like the work,
like there's nothing,
the only thing worse than performing in front of an outdoor audience is
performing in front of people who are eating.
Yeah.
Because this was like a tailgate at like 11:00 AM or 1:00 PM or something.
Yeah,
everybody's been,
you know,
everybody like busted out there like you know their marijuana brownie recipe for
the year.
They're all by completely looped,
you know,
like one of their eyes is completely dilated and the other one is like falling
out of their head.
Nobody cares about your jokes about your mom and your family.
So it was just like could not muster compassionate.
They tried.
So he starts doing stand up and he just immediately starts getting booed and
it's just this dislike,
this title wave of,
of,
of disdain.
And he knows if he doesn't finish he will not get paid.
But it's not like,
it's not like,
like silence you could tolerate.
Right.
But like people are screaming at him to get off stage and he,
he makes it very clear to the audience.
You have to watch it cause I'll never be able to do it justice.
But he makes it very clear to the audience that he is not leaving the stage
until he does his 10 minutes,
that he does not care how they feel about him.
And he's,
and he's counting down the minutes every minute.
He's like,
not admit it.
You fucking fuck.
He says living really outrageous.
Like,
I don't care.
Mother gets cancer,
the center of her asshole.
So it's,
it's,
so,
um,
it's,
it's just a demonstration of tenacity.
You know,
he,
he later,
you know,
he was embarrassed by it,
but every comedian understands,
you know,
this kind of,
this kind of blood battle that you sometimes have with an audience where you
know,
you're not,
they're not going to scare you and they're not going to drive you away.
You're going to deliver the material that you were hired to deliver.
You're going to make your money and then you're going to go off and spend it on
light beer and chicken wings.
But,
uh,
but no one is,
you will not be deterred.
And so,
um,
so I think because you understand that as a comedian very early on in your
career,
no matter what happens on stage,
uh,
you know,
I,
I will,
I will not be moved.
So I just,
I had material to do and I did it.
And I think I remember Ryan thinking almost immediately welcome.
I'm not going to any last.
So I'm just gonna kind of like listen to the set and see what it feels like,
see what the words feel like,
see what might play in front of actual people.
But,
but it started to get really delicious.
And I think if you watched the bill burr video,
you'll also see that he starts to really enjoy it.
It starts to be like this kind of like savory masochism towards the end where he
just,
he's so powerful in his,
in his,
in his lack of caring,
you know what I mean?
Like,
and,
uh,
and I,
you watch it and it's,
it is to be studied because he goes from kind of anguish to rage.
This kind of delightful detachment by the end of the set.
Uh,
and I've seen it,
I've seen some other guys do similar stuff and it's always really fun to watch.
So a couple of,
a couple of things that I want to use as teasers for people who should watch
this video.
I think,
I think it wasn't Phil.
I'm almost a hundred percent positive.
It was in Philadelphia.
I don't either that or Jersey but yeah,
I think it was Philadelphia because he started ridiculing rocky and he said your
hero is a fictional person and just tearing into them and he basically for the,
for half of his set,
just decided to abandon his material and just attack these people in the town.
And a way is a no,
no.
Generally no.
No.
Generally,
uh,
probably like if people hate you,
like you know,
there's,
I mean there were like these unwritten rules of comedy and one of them is like
you don't,
if some of the people in the audience,
hey,
you like don't turn all of them against you.
Yeah.
And this is just a sidebar,
but don't forget what you were going to say.
There's another very famous video,
very famous.
And it happened at the punchline in San Francisco where there's a,
Ha there's a guy playing,
he's a good guitar comic and a guy's heckling him and uh,
it's Kinda just a combative back and forth but nothing too extreme.
But then the guy gets up and he comes towards the AH,
the stage or you know,
whatever to defend himself or the girl is with something like that and the guy
just hauls off and hits him in the head with a gun.
Sorry.
Not Funny.
It's tragic.
But Jesus Christ,
you have any left.
What happens is up until that beat,
the whole audience has been on the comedian side against this guy and it is a,
it is a hairpin turn from them being like yeah,
shut up.
Cause it got,
because the,
you know the comics like hey you know,
people can enjoy the show cause you're talking keep,
you know,
keep it down.
And then he hits this guy in the whole audience just turns on him just like
instantaneous,
like
Frankenstein's monster mob just to pitch forks come flying out.
And so the,
one of the unwritten rules of comedy is that you know,
you,
you just don't,
you want to try to at all costs,
avoid turning everybody against
you,
which so so bill broke a bunch of rules but,
but he just,
he,
he never gave up,
you know,
which I think it becomes this,
it's like the Rudy moment at the end of the movie.
Like,
man,
that sucked.
But you sort of set in there and he got a standing of wall.
I mean every reserve standing,
but he got massive applause from the audience at the end,
which is just
like,
what the fuck?
Like it didn't even fit into like any mental sharistics of comedy that they
could expect.
It was freight prison that was straight prison yard dynamics.
Right?
Like nobody know
how to fight.
Right.
Just like the yard,
nobody backing down,
nobody's backing down.
And he just,
you know,
I think they,
there was like a thousand of them to want it for probably like 10,000 of them to
one of him.
And he just did not back down.
He got,
he got the slow with Spec clap at the end of God.
So I wasn't going to go to heckling,
but why not?
Since we're already here,
do you have any memorable heckling stores?
Did you recall the first time you got heckled?
God,
yeah,
I mean again,
I mean I started doing standup like 25 years ago.
So at this point like all the sets of just kind of blended,
but um,
and heckling can be lots of different things.
It doesn't always have to be like the conventional kind of use suck.
Haeckel I one I one time where this woman and this kind of dovetails perfectly
with the old,
like don't turn the audience against you.
Where this woman was talking to me,
she was sitting in the front row and she was talking to me the entire show,
just loud enough that I could hear her but not really loud enough so the
audience could hear her except for the people right around her.
And it was driving me crazy.
That's awful.
It was like a B in my ear.
And as a result,
I just seemed insane.
This topic to yell at this person that no one could hear.
It wasn't very effective echo because she just completely derailed my show and I
just seem like a Dick because I was,
you're like shut up lady and but no one could hear what she was saying.
Nice Lady.
And it really,
I mean it was,
I remember that I really went off the rails last night and I generally have a
rule with hecklers that unless they're really disruptive to the entire room,
I just never addressed them.
Because what you do is again,
you've derail a show for 500 or a thousand people to deal with one person and,
and,
and everyone's never gonna really understand what's going on unless that person
is so loud that they are,
that they're affected everybody else's enjoyment of the night.
Um,
but sometimes the affection hecklers are the worst because cause they don't,
you know,
typically hecklers just want to be a part of the show.
And so,
you know,
they say something is slammed them a little bit,
they shut up cause they think they're helping you out.
He was,
the famous line is they'll come up and be like,
hey,
you like how it helped you out.
I'm like,
buddy,
I came with jokes and I don't need this.
I don't,
I don't have a box jumper and my action right.
I showed up ready to go.
But um,
when people are affectionate,
you can't insult them and they're the,
they're the most unmanageable kind of how by affection you me.
So it was like I love you,
I love you.
I this one girl at one show in San Francisco,
just so drunk,
I'm just cross side.
And for that 90 minutes I was on state cause I love you.
And I was just like,
lady like your w w all you're doing is making me want to hit you in the head
with this microphone stand.
Your affection is,
is not welcome here.
And everybody else is like staring at this woman,
but she,
this is a genuine expression of emotion for this person that is destroying my
joy completely.
So,
um,
you know,
I,
if I really have a habit of just not talking to hecklers,
what did you do in that case?
Did you ignore?
I think that I kept saying like,
thank you,
that's super sweet.
Shut the fuck up.
But that was like,
like,
you know,
clearly you are and how good up as a child.
I mean,
I just eventually got mean because it was just like I couldn't get this woman to
stop talking.
Um,
and uh,
and I think the people around her got embarrassed and they eventually kind of
shut her up,
which was nice.
Um,
and I,
I'm trying to think,
are there any other really good Eckler's that,
uh,
oh,
I had one guy and it's a mental discipline too because,
you know,
like again,
like it's your show,
you have the microphone,
you're in control.
You know,
I think the audience thinks they're in control,
but they're not,
I mean that the build we're scenario is a perfect example.
The person with the microphone has all the power,
uh,
and as long as they,
as long as it can not be moved,
they will,
they will eventually win.
But I had,
um,
this one guy who was sitting really close to the stage,
it was like a group of 12 people and they were all like laughing their asses off
and then he was just arms crossed,
just look like he just had just eaten a big scoop of fecal matter.
And I just,
it was all,
he was all I could see,
like,
you know what I mean,
like the whole audience and disappeared.
And it was just like straight vignette on this guy's like sourpuss face and I
couldn't,
it was,
there was this wrecking my whole night.
And uh,
I finally said,
if you don't want to be here,
just fucking go,
man,
I'll give you your money back.
I cannot look at your face for one more minute.
And then I met him.
It wasn't even a joke.
I was just like,
get out and you are harshing my mellow so hard.
And,
and,
and uh,
and he left and I didn't feel bad about it.
And then I went out with a show and his girlfriend goes,
he had a bad day.
I was like,
but what was great was nobody else at the table,
one is leave.
They're all like,
you know,
good riddance to bad rubbish.
And He,
you know,
he went on and that's the people enjoy their night.
So,
but again,
that was me.
That was my,
you know,
I should have been disciplined enough not to be distracted by,
old,
Sour Puss,
but
I'm only human,
you know what I mean?
The Grinch's if the Grinch is sitting in the front row,
you know,
something must be done.
When you were just getting started,
how did you get better at comedy?
And what I mean by that is you're very smart.
Uh,
you,
like you mentioned matrix capable.
Uh,
did you do any type of postgame analysis?
Did you watch video of yourself?
Did Watch video of other
comics?
How did you hone your craft or eight or maybe a better question is what helped
the most in honing your craft?
That's a good question.
Um,
you know,
it's interesting,
like I think that there's definite math to comedy and then there's also a
secondary kind of like ineffability,
you know what I mean?
And,
and I guess what I mean is like you can learn how to be a better comic,
but you can't learn how to be a comic or even had a different way.
I really wanted to be an engineer and I could have really suffered and struggled
through like that high,
like the elevated math.
It would,
I would need to become an engineer,
but it would never be effortless for me.
And I think with comedy there are people who very workmanlike can learn how to
do comedy and then there's some people were just naturally comedic and they
still have to work to be better at it.
You know,
like you say,
bolts still has to train,
even though he was born with,
you know,
more fast twitch muscles and everybody else,
he still has to train to become a champion.
So I feel like with comedy there,
you know,
people can be the class clown and it can be like,
I was naturally funny.
There's still a methodology and there's still a mathematics to becoming a comic.
And then at the same time,
if they have this,
this ephemeral,
ineffable kind of understanding of the math of comedy,
they're going to be able to do something magical with those skills.
So for me,
I don't know that I thought I was a funny kid,
but I was an observer and I wasn't really nerdy and a little bit of a social
pariah.
So story telling me came a way to make friends,
you know what I mean?
Like to like a gray shape myself.
I would,
I,
you know,
I would kind of like try to talk my way into situations or if I was in a social
situation,
talk really fast to try to keep myself engaging,
not be,
not be rejected.
Um,
so like that was what I brought to,
it was like that combination of being an outsider and an observer and then,
and then using those skills to try to kind of connect with people.
Um,
but w with comedy,
like I never took any classes.
I never read any books.
You know,
they're,
they're definitely people who can say,
Oh,
you know,
there's a total methodology to comedy.
It's,
you know,
the rule of threes and you know,
stretch,
stretching,
the stretching reality to the point of breaking but not pass it.
I mean they're,
you know,
some specific,
what's the rule of threes?
Oh,
the rule of threes is that,
um,
I definitely maintain your train of thought,
but I probably won't even be able to articulate it properly.
It's,
it's just that like if you're going to do a series of jokes or a series of
builds to a punchline,
it needs to be three I guess.
And also if you're going to do any kind of a of a diversion,
if you're going to lead people in one direction,
then snap around to a different kind of absurdist results.
You can't do that in a,
you can't do that in two.
It has to.
That has to be,
it has to be,
the pace of it has to be three.
I see.
Um,
and then pass through.
You're starting to,
you know,
draw things out too long.
But two doesn't give people enough of a time.
All the,
to a false sense of security before you kind of pulled the rug out from under
them.
Um,
and then as soon as you start explaining that at the math of,
of comedy,
like none of it makes any sense.
You know what I mean?
Like it's this,
it's those two things.
You know,
someone who's really gifted at physics there,
they know that there are rules,
but still they see things that other people can't see.
You know what I mean?
They,
they see the world as numbers and the data and the rest of us are just like
table chair,
water sec.
Um,
so I guess the way that I did it was that I ha I'm also really an on disciplined
comedian.
And what I mean is like,
um,
like there's a,
there's a documentary about Gary Shandling out right now,
which I haven't watched,
but um,
but I'm sure that this is in there because he was very famous for being a really
disciplined writer.
Like he would get up and he would write every single day.
And sometimes it would be pages and pages of material without fail other comics.
Like,
Hey,
let's get a beer and be like,
no,
I have to write.
And everyday he would write like on this like legal,
this is,
this is probably true.
And Apocrypha at the same time on this,
like legal,
I knew about these tiny handwriting and he would just write and write and write
and write.
I do not do that.
I've never worked that way.
Um,
I just get on stage.
I try a bunch of stuff.
I keep what works.
I know what works.
I already know right away what works.
I'll run off stage,
I'll write down the things that I knew hit,
I'll write down the things I know didn't hit,
and then I'll go back and try it again.
Dropping the stuff that wasn't good and putting new stuff in.
I record my sets,
but I never,
I cannot listen to my own voice.
So I have hours and hours of material on tape that I just have never listened
to.
So I don't know why I still engage in that behavior when it's clearly not useful
to me.
But,
um,
but I,
I,
I think the more you do it,
the more you intuitively understand that this is a rich area.
People are connecting with this,
this other stuff.
There's also something you learned s as you move through comedy,
which is,
is not just important to get a laugh.
Like does this material say something specific and personal about me?
Because when you're a baby comic,
every joke is meaningful to you cause he only have like eight jokes,
right?
And so even if they're stupid or juvenile or unsophisticated or,
or,
or valueless or,
or coreless,
you'll still do that because that's all you have.
And then as you get older you start thinking,
okay,
like I want to have a body of work here.
Does this hang together?
Does it have a strong point of view?
Does it have an identity?
And then those are the jokes start to fall away.
And then the material really becomes about trying to tell some kind of a story
about yourself and the way you perceive the world.
And then that's how you shape that.
And so sometimes things that are really funny go away.
Things that are less funny stay because they,
they're more impactful.
Does that make sense?
Yeah,
it does make sense.
Um,
absolutely.
Yeah.
For musicians,
I think it's true for
writers to probably for writers it's like I'm going to find a space that's,
that really says something about like my accumulated understanding and knowledge
of the world.
And it's not just enough to say something like I need to say something that's
uniquely mine,
you know?
And as something you can only do with,
by being prolific because you need to be able to let things go in order to
figure out what should stay.
Definitely.
Yeah.
There's,
I mean there's a certain volume to it or the thinking of it almost as a funnel
and uh,
you know,
I think,
and I certainly hope for the sake of our,
not to sound like an old man,
but I guess that's what I'm turning into a for the sake of our just
society in general.
I would hope just seeing the number of hatchet jobs and the amount of yellow
journalism and click baiting with pieces that have not been fact checked and so
on.
Uh,
and take down pieces of folks who are otherwise doing actually a lot of good in
the world,
but,
um,
people feeling no compunction about running pieces that get a lot of clicks
because that's the only metric they're focused on at some point.
Go from,
you know,
what,
what can I write that will get the most clicks to what can I write that I will
be proud of?
That may or may not.
Yeah,
I think you can figure out a way to make it a non-binary decision.
Uh,
in other words,
you could figure out something you can be proud of that is simultaneously,
uh,
likely to have fun to find some type of sizable audience.
Right.
And,
uh,
I think in the beginning there's a temptation,
particularly if you have quit your job and you're like,
where's my next rent check coming from?
How can I appeal to the widest number of people possible?
And that's a very precarious position,
a or mindset to put yourself into if you're hoping to do anything creatively.
Yeah.
Uh,
Evergreen.
Right.
And I also like,
it's interesting like,
you know,
like when I went to school,
we had,
we had the,
you know,
the honor system and,
and,
and you were just expected to hold yourself to a high standard because that was
what was right.
That's what you did.
You know what I mean?
You just,
you were going to be,
we're going to be called upon to stand behind your work and,
and so you tried to work very hard to make sure that you can defend it.
I think that,
I don't think that it's like we're any less ethical than we've ever been.
It's just like you said,
our metrics have changed.
Like,
and I think that people value fame for fame's sake rather than for the,
like the foundational reasons that people become famous and,
and I think that's the problem.
And I don't think it just exists in journalism.
I think,
I think that people value infamy or they can't distinguish between fame and
infamy.
And you know,
with a 24 hour news cycle,
like,
you know,
uh,
bright burst is as meaningful as a slow burn.
And I don't really know.
I don't,
I actually don't really know what we do or what,
what should be done or what should happen to counteract that other than people
start to maybe get hip to it and start rejecting,
you know,
baseless journalism and,
and,
you know,
it's just,
it's just so hard to describe.
I don't know.
I find it,
I me take that back.
I find it very easy to distinguish between things that seem like they've been
thoroughly vetted and things that are bullshit.
But I think that people are working very hard to make it harder for the rest of
us to distinguish between the two.
So there are,
you know,
without me sounding like a crazy person,
there aren't a Pfarius,
you know,
forces at work trying to make it very hard for us to figure out what's real and
what's not real.
And I think we have to start to raise people who are just more critical
thinkers.
But it's hard to be a critical thinker when you're just scrolling through your
Instagram feed,
looking at like butts and cupcakes.
How long
have you been watching my,
my feet?
Are you looking over my shoulder or are you one of the nefarious forces and
following you and I know,
I know what you're into.
I see what you got.
You know,
I have to all admit there was a day and you would think supposedly being a tech
investor and all this stuff for 10 years that I would figure this out.
There was a day when I was scrolling through cupcakes and thongs and I looked up
at my flat,
my profile,
and I was like,
wait a minute.
People can see what I follow.
And I was like,
Oh fuck.
Uh,
you know,
fortunately I've,
I've systematically dismantled and deliberately tarnished any semblance of any
reputation I might have very deliberately so that I feel so that I don't feel
doing you now.
This is so interesting.
So that I don't feel I have any Stepford wives polished persona to purse to
preserve.
Right?
Yeah.
Oh
good.
That's so interesting to me.
And it's different than just being a slob.
What you're seeing is I refuse to create a box within which I will be kept by
others.
And I think like that comes also from a curiosity about the world.
I actually think that like people were trying to remain perfect all the time.
Our fear-driven like that's not,
that's not,
that's not a,
that's not a position of strength.
You're not meeting,
people think they're maintaining position of strength when they're trying to
maintain an appearance of perfection.
But that is by its very nature,
a posture of fear,
which is I cannot be seen to have imperfections that cannot be seen to have
flaws.
I,
there can be no chinks in my armor and,
and,
and that's,
I have,
I am terrified of being judged,
but there's something very liberating and I think it comes from age as well.
And from experience,
I don't mean experience like a resume,
but like just having experiences to realize how little you know and how the only
way to learn is to constantly be like skinning your knees and that,
that doesn't go away.
Like in the older you get,
the more you know that you know very little and that you cannot learn if you are
constantly trying to maintain a posture of perfection.
Absolutely.
And that's why I'm a total mess.
What if you don't,
if you don't practice skinning your knees just to like really bleed the metaphor
for all it's worth,
if you don't practice skinning your knees,
you're not going to develop the Callus for ink,
sort of increasingly painful grades of sandpaper.
This is really awkwardly,
uh,
overextended now.
But the point being,
if you operate from a place of fear and want to please,
this is nebulous majority more than you want to please yourself.
Uh,
and that's not to say that I'm always,
I've always viewed my tire life and all my decisions as a singular locus of
control and the palm of my hand and I care what no one thinks.
That's not true because that's not how humans evolved.
But if you are,
if you are deferring to others,
your perception of what others want a on the small things,
then it's going to become harder on the medium things and then impossible,
and then it's going to become harder and impossible on the big things.
And for that reason,
I find it very valuable to a deliberately expose yourself to different types and
levels of discomfort so that you can actually stand up for the important stuff
when it matters.
Because if you don't practice on the smaller stuff,
for instance,
I,
if,
if I'm so humiliated by the fact that I liked gorgeous female acids and I'm
like,
oh my God,
and I put something up about,
I put up this picture.
So this is what I do occasionally when I'm like,
you know what?
I think I'm getting a little,
a little fat and happy and complacent and maybe I have too much fomo or
something like that.
I will,
I remember at one point this,
I put up this photo of this gorgeous,
the Latin ass and I'm female and uh,
and it said like Nego Ophelia and I had this in Spanish,
this explanation of this fake condition,
which was nego fee nego Ophelia.
Anyway,
I think it was not enough for you to anyway,
Les Nuggets.
It's like ass and in Spanish.
And so anyway,
so I put this up on Instagram.
That's right.
It's Spanish for like ass man ass man syndrome.
Right?
Or ask me,
I disorder and I put it up and it is to be expected.
There is immediate outreach.
I mean,
there are there plenty of people who think it's kind of funny.
Plenty of people who are like,
yeah,
high five.
And then there are plenty of other people who are just completely outraged,
disgusted with this fact that I find attractive women.
Attractive and outrageous.
Yeah.
It's so,
uh,
but I left it up,
because I like to call my audience number one.
Uh,
you don't want to be here please.
I invite you to unfollow and yeah,
exactly right.
Like,
it's like the sour puss in the front row.
It's like,
let me give you,
like,
you look,
you look like you're unhappy,
but you're still here.
And let me give you,
let me give you another reason to leave if I'm not your thing,
because go find something else.
Opinion is valuable to you.
Like I think there's a freedom in saying I don't need everybody to like me.
I that's,
you know what I mean?
I think,
I think that like there is something very meaningful and saying like,
this is who I am.
I'll defend it,
but I'm not here to be savaged by you.
And honestly,
we don't know each other.
I don't care what you think and the way you know,
um,
uh,
or maybe that person makes you think more critically about what you did and then
you take the big booty picture down.
I don't know.
But,
uh,
but I think you put it up purposefully to see what you were going to get back.
I totally did entertaining and there another other,
there are cases just so I don't sound like a complete Dick.
Uh,
there are other cases where I put something up without really thinking about it
and I do get feedback and realize,
you know what,
that's actually a really kind of insensitive thing to put up.
And I didn't think it through.
Take it down there.
There are cases when they do that and people give me hopefully constructive
feedback that isn't just spitting acid into my face and that,
and I take it down.
So I do pay attention.
Uh,
at the same time,
I try to keep in mind,
uh,
advice that I was given years ago.
I don't remember who gave me this advice,
but they said the advice was,
it's not about how many people don't get it.
It's about how many people get it.
So as long as you have a certain critical mass,
whatever that means to you.
And there's an article called 1000 true fans by Kevin Kelly that everybody
should read to this effect if you're creative.
But as long as you have a critical mass,
and it can be a very small number of people who love your stuff,
pay it,
that's all that matters.
That's like a pass fail,
right?
As long as you have that pass,
like you're green and instead of focusing on the vast majority who hate your
shit,
it's like,
look,
there are millions of people who hate like Christopher Nolan stuff.
There are millions of people who can't stand Wes Anderson.
It's like,
look,
some people just aren't going to fucking like Wes Anderson.
Exactly.
Exactly that.
So it's really interesting also because I think if you're an artist
specifically,
this is a really important conversation to have with yourself,
which is like when I first started at at stand up,
you know,
this was like kind of the period where like def comedy jam was really popular
and you know,
and,
and for,
for lack of a better way of articulating it,
like black comedy had a very specific look and feel and style and tempo.
And I just wasn't doing that kind of comedy and I wasn't ever going to be able
to do that kind of comedy.
It wasn't who I was.
It wasn't experientially what I was doing.
And I didn't want to lie.
And I knew that were comedians who were kind of falling into that stylistic
approach to comedy and it was really very false.
You know,
they,
they'd kind of be one way offstage and then kind of fall into this character on
stage.
And there's nothing wrong with trying to connect with an audience,
but I just didn't want to copy other people to try to get people to like me.
And you know,
for a long time I really struggled and then eventually my tribe found me but I
was able to stay.
Oh now I sound like a self help book.
But like true to who I was because that was the only way forward.
The only way forward as an artist is to be,
is to be truthful in end.
Your work is not going to be interesting or meaningful if you were trying to
emulate somebody else or trying to figure out what people want from you or what
they like or what's popular.
Meaningful art only last.
It only connects if it's,
if it's authentic and if it comes from euro,
your own personal experiences.
And if,
and until you figure that out,
like what that is,
it's never going to be interesting.
It's never going to be good.
And I always tell people it's not being funny is not really actually the most
important part of comedy being truthful is because if someone sees a good show
they go,
that guy was really funny.
But when you tell the truth about yourself,
people go,
oh my God,
Holy Shit,
that guy like spoke to me or about me or was so vulnerable in that moment.
Like that was amazing.
And that's the difference between good comedy and great comedy or big queen,
good art,
great art or writing or anything.
Yeah,
that's truth.
That's,
that's advice that I've also heard for screenwriting and many other things.
It's like,
yeah,
uh,
I'm so glad you said that and reminded me of that.
These yourself,
I mean you just have to please your self period cause it might not go your way
anyway.
But the worst thing is creating something.
I figured out what people want and then creating some piece of shit,
some like crass,
you know,
Glib,
solicitous piece of shit and people don't buy it anyway.
Why not make something you love and the people don't buy and least it was
something that you love,
then you're not embarrassed by it.
Right.
And you said it may not work out.
And if you're in the creative game,
at least from what I've seen,
particularly in the beginning,
most things are not going to work out and nothing ever goes away.
Right?
So,
so you might as well have one person who's happy about the process and uh,
exactly.
And uh,
saying about engagement,
at least the experience was satisfying.
And I would also,
I feel like I'm talking too much,
so I'm going to,
I'm going to stop in a second.
But the,
the,
uh,
the other,
the other thought I might underscore for folks that is kind of practical,
tactical,
from a competitive standpoint,
if you're trying to play someone else's game by taking on a persona,
someone who is actually in,
for instance,
in the def comedy jam example that you gave,
right?
If somebody is on stage and they're playing their game,
that is who they are.
You are never going to be able to take on like the cognitive load and the
fatigue of pretending to be that type of person and beat someone who is good at
that game.
You're just not going to,
so here's so right.
Yeah.
You're just not going to win.
So it's like you,
you will not ultimately in any field that is competitive,
which is effectively every field that people get paid for.
Uh,
the,
Oh,
if you want to be the best,
you actually,
you have to harness your latent abilities and,
or you're fucked.
Like you can't,
like you mentioned,
uh,
on the engineering front of me,
there's so many places where,
for instance,
in writing,
it's like I could try to be,
uh,
John McPhee who writes for the New Yorker or one of these folks,
but I can't be those people.
I'm not going to be,
I'm not going to ever be the word Smith that say a Tolstoy was,
but,
uh,
do I like teaching?
Do I obsessively think about teaching and deconstructing things that are
complex?
I do.
So I can use books as a medium for teaching and thinking of it.
Think of it that way.
Because if I try to be,
if I tried to out nicotinic fee,
I'm going to get my face ripped off.
Okay.
And um,
well,
you know,
th this is,
we're talking about creativity and creative pursuits,
which by the way,
almost everything is even if you were,
uh,
if you,
if you meet people who are the top of their game in accounting at the top of the
game,
I'm not talking about shady,
uh,
money laundering shit.
I'm just saying in accounting,
in,
uh,
technology,
there's an element,
there's certainly an element of creativity.
If you're looking at the people who are really at the top and innovating in any
way doing exceptional work,
you have done so many different things.
You know,
acting,
comedy,
directing,
writing,
activism.
You've been a host,
you've done voiceover,
you have,
you've engaged in so many different acts of creation.
I want to talk about short films,
films and so on.
I want to talk about movies
because as long term listeners will know,
I've been,
uh,
sort of teasing with the idea,
which by the way just means procrastinating of right.
Writing some short films and I'm,
I'm still at step zero and I'm ashamed of that.
But,
uh,
no shame.
There's no shame.
Yeah.
So how did you,
how did you decide to get into film and why?
I mean,
film is hot.
Film is heart.
Why do it?
Yeah,
it is tough.
Yeah.
Like,
so that's a really good question cause I feel like there's the,
you know,
that like really humiliating,
kind of,
you know,
clam,
uh,
about,
you know,
well,
I'm an actor,
but what I really wanted to do is direct them and,
and it feels very cliched.
I feel like it was more organic for me because I,
you know,
I,
again,
I wasn't someone who kind of,
I didn't go to film school.
Uh,
and I also don't think I had the Hubris to think like,
Oh,
I've done this a cup for a couple of years now I can direct it was,
I had written some,
I love movies.
Like,
you know,
we were talking earlier,
I was raised by a single dad and you know,
I,
I was one of those kids who like,
I'd go,
I'd go with my dad to see like diehard or road warrior and you know what way too
early of age,
super inappropriate.
Um,
you know,
or like by the time,
like when I was in high school,
I'd seen the terminator like the First Terminator from like 20 or 30 times.
Like I,
I just loved movies.
I'd go to the theater,
I buy matinee ticket nights,
stay in the theater until like eight o'clock at night.
And I would just like watch movie after movie after movie.
And so it just came out of a,
like a real end users love for film.
Like I was just someone who was transported by movies.
And then when,
when I left talk soup,
um,
I had been writing on that show and,
and like there was a void and I wrote a script that I was developing with a,
with a company and,
and I just kept talking about how I thought it should look and how I thought it
should feel.
And you know,
it was just so much more specific than being a writer and they,
they were like,
you know,
you should direct,
this is clearly like a movie that you should direct.
And I hadn't really thought about it,
but I was just so intertwined with the material and what I wanted it to feel
like because I know what I,
what movies that I love make me feel like that I wanted that if someone is
create that experience for other people.
And I just realized like I didn't,
I wasn't,
I couldn't,
I didn't know what directing entailed.
I didn't have any idea about what that was going to be like.
And I just went away and started trying to learn about directing.
And so I kind of would call people that I knew that were directors.
If I wasn't working on something,
I would ask to come back to set when I wasn't working so I can hang out and
shadow,
which is where you just kinda hang around behind the director and watch them
work.
And I ended up shadowing with some really incredible people.
Ended up spending several days on the wire and it's last season and wow.
Yeah.
And just got to just be on the other side of a process that can be relatively
opaque when you're an actor,
you're just kind of show up and say your lines and leave.
And um,
and then I started making shorts and I,
and I guess this is going to sound very Glib,
but uh,
cause I mean I'm sure I have the resources available to me that lots of people
don't.
But I do feel,
I do believe in it.
Like I just believe in personal aggression.
Like I just believe in doing stuff,
said personal aggression,
depression.
Like I just believe that like if you want to make a movie,
just start making a movie.
And I don't mean like,
oh,
get a camera and start shooting it.
But what I do mean is like be be hard on yourself.
Like learn,
read,
learn,
watch,
study.
I think critically ask people questions and then make a movie and then let it be
shitty and then make another one and let that one be shitty and keep doing it
until you get better at it.
Like the first short film I made was,
I mean it's an abomination.
It will be never see the light of day.
I had no idea what I was doing,
but that didn't make me not want to be a director.
It just made me realize I needed to learn more.
And then I uh,
I started to feel like I was more ready and I was like,
I need to make some stuff.
So first thing was I did a comedy central Special Ed and I took the money.
That would have been my salary and I use it to make us like a little short music
video that opens the comedy special.
It wasn't anything that was mandated by the network.
I was like,
I want to do something different.
So I wrote this song and I performed it and I made music video and that was the
kind of the first thing I directed.
I just use the crew that was already working on the,
on the special and,
and shot video with that.
That's really smart.
So I would imagine,
not to interject,
but you piggybacked on something that was in your main line business,
so to speak.
Exactly.
I imagine you saved a lot of costs by doing that,
right?
I mean,
you had like,
yeah.
Yeah.
Like,
like the guy,
the crew was already going to come up the day before and leave the day after to
shoot the special.
Um,
and we'd already rented the cameras and everything like that.
Uh,
but I had to sell it to pay them for the extra workers.
Took my,
I took my fee and I used it to pay everybody else.
Um,
and then,
and then because I didn't have any more money after that,
I,
I learned how to edit it.
I edited it myself and I delivered it to the network because I couldn't afford
to pay for additional at at time.
Um,
and then after that I thought,
okay,
I,
uh,
I want to do more of this.
So then I,
um,
I rented a camera,
rented like a Canon Five d and I had some friends who were in bands.
And again,
like it sounds fancy,
but everybody probably knows somebody who does something,
you know,
it just,
cause I had some friends who were in a famous band doesn't mean that people out
that don't have friends were in bands.
So I just called some buddies of mine that were in bands and I said,
hey,
if you let me come on tour with you,
I will make you a free music video.
Just a piece of fan art.
You can use it however you like.
I'm not going to charge anybody any money for it,
but just,
I,
I want to make something and I want to make something for you.
Um,
and so I ended up going on the road with Silversun pickups for a couple of dates
and then spending a day with clutch when they're performing an Anaheim.
And then I just gave them,
I just cut music videos and delivered it to them.
Um,
and so then I just started to have like examples of what I could do,
why,
why music videos instead of something else.
It just felt like a way to get more people to see it.
Um,
I had done that first music video for my comedy central special,
which was really like a comedic video.
But then I was like,
oh,
I really like working in this space.
And a lot of directors come out of music video because you can be kind of
radically creative and that space,
you don't have need to have any like narrative linearity.
You can experiment,
you can be radical.
It could just be like a series of images.
Um,
and I also thought,
well,
people who,
who like this band and I love,
I love this band will want to see something that about them.
It'll be a great way for people to see something and then hopefully I can tell a
story at the same time.
Um,
so I did three of those and then I did a little action short.
Like I just kind of kept making stuff and you know,
every time I did it I learned something.
Every time I did it,
I took a bigger risk.
Creatively.
How,
how long are these shorts?
Like three to five minutes.
Three to five minutes.
Can you think of any particular lessons that you took away from any one of
those?
Yeah,
like I think a lot of it was just skill building.
Like how do you frame up and how do you make choices and how do you do coverage
and you know,
uh,
and the,
how do you edit?
Like a lot of it was just really tactical as you would say,
practical,
tactical,
uh,
stealing it from to,
and then,
um,
and then a lot of it was just calm.
Like,
just getting confident with my own ability and my ability to articulate.
I wanted,
uh,
from other people,
you know,
just how to,
how do the other jobs on a set work,
who does what,
what do I need?
Oh God,
this didn't work.
You know,
I didn't work because I didn't have this kind of a person on set.
Like,
you know,
w w w we,
I was shooting digitally and then on one show a on one of my things that I shot,
like we didn't have,
um,
uh,
like a tack on set,
on set to like,
to help me make sure that it looked the way that I wanted it to look like,
that the levels are set properly.
So when I got home to edit it,
like add some problems,
but like,
it wasn't,
they weren't,
they were catastrophic problems.
They were just because,
because I,
you know,
I wasn't making star wars,
you know what I mean?
I was just able to be like,
well,
this is what it is and I'm gonna make this and move on.
And,
and then,
um,
I was getting ready to,
I really wanted to do a feature.
I didn't,
I had some material I'd written but it was kind of going to be an expensive
movie,
but I was still shadowing.
So I had friend who had a show called penny dreadful.
I let John Logan and create a penny dreadful.
I've met him at comic con hosted the panel for that show and he was like,
hey,
why don't you,
you love the show,
you should come visit us in Ireland.
And I remember thinking like to myself,
people always say that and then you always say,
yeah,
then you never do it.
I was like,
I'm going to do it.
I'm fucking going on Ireland,
man.
That's,
I'm going to be cool.
I'm getting,
I want to,
I will say I'm going to be a cool kid for once in my life at a and so I ended up
going over visiting penny dreadful and vikings shot right up the road.
So I got them to let me visit that set.
I just hung out at like passed out sandwiches and you know,
lifted stuff and ask questions and watch them work.
And,
and then while I was over there,
I met a bunch of,
uh,
Irish actors and,
and,
and one of them,
two of them actually,
one was,
it was a,
was an actor,
composer and one was a writer,
a screenwriter and an actor.
And we ended up making a short film together in Ireland at the end of 2014.
That was my first narrative short,
my first kind of story-driven short.
Uh,
and it was,
it was just great.
It was just like,
I was like,
oh,
this is like totally who I am.
This is what I want to do with my life.
And where did you film in Ireland and in Gull Bay and Galway,
which is a beautiful tone.
Yeah.
Such a great place for a month in 2005 thing.
All that's so cool.
Credible arts festival there.
It's a really beautiful spot.
It is.
It's like,
it's,
it's like the arts center of,
of Ireland.
You know,
they've got a beautiful film festival in the summer.
They've got an arts festival,
you know,
like local theater.
And,
um,
it was just a great experience.
Uh,
and,
you know,
things went wrong and things went right,
but you know,
we got it in the can in three days and it was just super cool and personal.
And then,
uh,
that same writer who had written that Short,
had a feature he had already written and he asked me if I wanted to take a look
at it and it was just a perfect first film and that that's the film that became
access.
Okay.
So I want to dig in to access,
but before we get to that,
you're taking these trips,
doing these music videos during that period,
are you,
did you save up for that period noting knowing that you would need to work out
of your savings?
Are you depending on royalties and other streams to pay your bills?
How are you covering the necessities of life as you were handing out sandwiches
and doing all these various things?
Okay.
Well it wasn't a,
it wasn't as prolonged of a period is it sounds like I was on hiatus.
Um,
so like,
uh,
I was,
I was working on,
I was working on the talk at the time and we get a month off every year,
so I went in that month.
Um,
but I think if I was talking to a lay person who didn't work in television,
I,
I would,
I would say like,
you know,
if,
if what you want is to grow in whatever field you're interested in,
like,
just create a space for that.
Like,
you know,
make that your vacation,
like,
I didn't,
it wasn't like,
I like was like riding around in a limousine.
Like I just flew over and I hung around,
you know,
for like a week and watch people work.
And,
um,
it,
it wasn't any more or less burdensome than taking a vacation.
Uh,
but I,
but one thing I was more interested in doing as I got older and we started with
this in the beginning,
it's like you said it,
I know,
and I,
I think we kind of went past it,
but it's so interesting to me.
It was,
I just,
I was more,
I just really wanted more discomfort in my life.
I was like,
you know,
it's just very easy.
The older you get to be like a,
you know,
get in car,
go to work,
eat bag,
lunch,
get in car,
go to the gym,
go home,
eat food,
watch TV,
go to bed.
And then you just think like,
am I my growing?
Like,
it's like any of this interesting.
Am I going to,
you know what I mean?
Like I have one life and I'm just spending it in this like torpor.
And so,
um,
for that I was going to a place where,
I mean,
I knew I knew one guy at at petty dreadful,
but I didn't know anybody at this other show.
And I just kind of cold called them and said,
you know,
can I,
can I come visit?
And they were super gracious.
Okay.
I'm so curious just to interrupt you.
You yet again.
What does that mean?
What does that email say?
Uh,
it says,
um,
hi.
Uh,
and again,
I understand that maybe this is going to feel a little rarefied.
Hi,
I'm an American actress.
I,
I've worked on these shows.
I'm,
I'm Chad,
I've been shadowing to direct for a long time.
I would be really grateful if I could come and visit your show for a few days
and shadow.
Um,
and I will be as unobtrusive and,
and,
um,
and invisible as I possibly can.
Uh,
and I'll be here these days and,
and um,
you know,
I understand if you can't accommodate me,
but I,
I really be grateful and I think it helped in my particular case because I had
tweeted a lot about how much I loved Vikings.
So we kind of knew that I was a big fan of the show and I,
and I did.
So tweeting from sat,
you know,
I kind of,
I kind of like,
I
paid my way in,
in,
uh,
you know,
like flacking their show for them.
But,
um,
which can occur just to,
I,
I'm not over caffeinated.
I swear to God,
I'm just,
you're making,
you're making so many important points that I just want to pause and help,
uh,
well as much for myself as anyone else,
just people to reflect on what you did in terms of tweeting.
People might say,
well I don't have a verified account and nobody's going to pay attention to one
tweet and the the,
the Twitter feed of 10,000 if it's a popular TV show.
But I can tell you from personal experience that you could for instance,
write something for medium or for fill in the blank outlet that has a high
Google another.
In other words,
page rank and to end that many of the producers,
actors and so on.
We'll have Google alerts or other alerts set that deliver to their inboxes.
Relevant media that mentioned say the show or the actors and you do not need to
be a famous actress or an author or any of those things to do that.
Do you,
is,
is his work at the highest possible caliber of quality that you can,
I mean,
I think you also touched on this,
about the idea that people are like more interested in being expeditious than
they are in the,
and being good.
I think that,
you know,
that this holds very,
very true for this business.
A lot of people have gotten,
have,
have made headway because they did something that nobody saw.
But when they,
when people ask them what they did,
the thing they were able to show was extraordinary.
And I don't mean like expensive,
extraordinary.
I just mean unique and personal and,
and crafted with care.
And so if that's something that you wrote or if it's something that you made,
if you made,
you know,
the number of,
I mean,
this is not the best example,
but it's a,
it's a good one.
20 years ago there was this video tape going around Hollywood,
uh,
the of these guys in an apartment.
Uh,
and it was a VHS tape.
That's how long ago it was.
Uh,
people were dubbing it and sending and giving to friends of these guys.
And Department of these three black guys where the one guy goes up and it's the
little inner comma goes was that,
and then the other guy,
because it was a high and the third guy,
one that was a short film that some guy made on like a digital camera.
None of them were famous.
They were just some guys in New York that ended up being that Budweiser
campaign.
That's crazy.
I had no idea that was the origin.
It was a short film and it wasn't.
It was a,
it was a two and a half minute short film.
That was just funny.
You didn't know who was it?
He didn't,
we didn't know these guys.
No one knew who they were and and they didn't have any connections and I think
it was just about doing something that felt original and personal.
And I get,
it just comes back to like,
don't try to figure out what people want,
just do what's interesting and important to you and then keep doing it until you
come up with something extraordinary.
And that will be your calling card and made it happen as fast as you want or as
aggressively as you honor,
as expansively as you want.
But in the meantime,
you're doing cool shit,
which should be your primary goal in any event.
Um,
you know,
and when,
when I made access,
honestly I just wanted to make a movie to show people I could make a movie.
I wanted to make the best movie I could.
And I was very rigorous in,
in leveraging the resources that I had to the best of my ability.
But I,
I,
I don't know that it had a lot of expectations that a lot of people would see
it.
It's just because I made the best movie I could that,
you know,
it got all of this attention,
but I,
but I don't think I was going in my,
like,
this is going to be a massive hit.
I was like,
I'm gonna make this little movie.
And then for the next one when people say,
well,
what have you done?
I can be like,
look at this little king I made.
You know?
So I think you have to always be focused on the results,
not the result on the thing and not the result because the result is directly
tied to the quality of the thing.
So it's not about infamy,
it's about fame and famous based on quality of your work.
So just be doing excellent shit all the time.
And eventually one of those things will connect with other people.
Yeah.
Not to sound like a fortune cookie on top of all of that public.
The,
the only uncrowded market is great.
Like there's always a fucking market for great.
Yeah,
exactly.
And,
and,
and to like,
and like be radically great.
Like don't be like,
I saw 10 things like this.
Let me do the 11th thing.
Like be brave enough to court failure.
That's probably when you're going to do something great.
Absolutely.
And if you get,
if you are really in love with something,
and I'll give two examples.
If you're really in love with say,
screenplays and film or if you're really in love and passionate about maybe is a
better word,
a possessed by technology investing early stage technology,
investing two phenomena to uh,
uh,
companies at this point,
certainly that are worth looking at and just investigating the stories of,
uh,
demonstrate very clearly what you can do if you are just rejected by the
establishment or if you want to not operate within the existing power structure
to it.
So the two examples are the blacklist look up Franklin Leonard and the blacklist
ample.
Absolutely.
And then the second is,
and we,
we don't have to get into both of these right now.
The second is just by coincidence also has the list at the end,
but angel list and naval Ravikant and people can look up.
Uh,
the,
well the avenging angel was the title of his interview and his alumni magazine
at Dartmouth.
In fact,
uh,
but,
um,
I get excited when I,
when I hear these types of stories.
So this check them out.
And this let's come back to,
let's come back to access.
Oh,
sure.
What is access?
And did you,
did you have anybody try to talk you out of doing access?
Um,
out?
That's such a good question.
Well,
so access is a thriller,
um,
about,
uh,
about an expatriate Irish actor who living in Los Angeles who has had a lot of
success,
kind of explosive success in his youth.
And it's really just used all of his resources to just wreck his life.
You know,
he's,
he's a drunk and he's a drug addict and he's terrible at relationships and is it
dick to everybody?
Um,
and,
uh,
and when we,
when we meet him,
he's trying to turn his life around.
Uh,
and,
and it,
and it's really about a guy who's not a bad person,
but he's done,
done some bad stuff,
which I think almost every human being can relate to,
you know,
I mean,
we all,
we all have a little bit of a demon inside of us and I think this is just a guy
who's been,
he's,
he,
he's been frail in the past,
but he's really trying to be a better version of himself,
but slowly over the course of an afternoon and the movie takes place in real
time as he's driving through Los Angeles,
uh,
his,
his life starts to unravel.
And it's really about him trying to hold things together,
trying to be a better person,
trying to be a better person in his relationships with his family,
with people that he works with.
Um,
just trying to,
trying to be better.
Uh,
it's really dark.
It's very funny.
Uh,
I,
I have been thinking about this,
I'm sure I'll get some letters about this,
but I happened to find a,
that addicts are really entertaining people
and I don't mean they're funny,
like,
like laugh at them.
I,
I find that they,
um,
that typically people who are,
uh,
who have broke,
who broken themselves down are just more honest than people were trying to be
perfect all the time.
And so,
um,
you know,
he's just,
he's,
he's a guy who's self aware.
He's aware of the mistakes he's made.
So it's a very darkly funny movie.
Uh,
and then it's very twisty.
It's,
it's a thriller.
So it's got a lot of secrets,
uh,
and at the most unique aspect of the movies that the whole thing takes place in
real time inside a car as he's driving through Los Angeles.
So the,
the lead actress,
the only actor on screen and all the other actors are our voice actors on the
phone with him.
What was your,
how would you describe your experience of being involved with this film?
It was so wonderful.
You asked if people tried to dissuade me from doing it.
And the short answer is in,
in Hollywood,
the way that people dissuade you from doing stuff,
it's just by not,
do not helping you to find out if he did.
If he says you don't even get no,
you just get like silence.
But,
but this happened very quickly,
so I didn't have a traditional kind of like discouraging period of frustration
with trying to put this movie together because I read it,
uh,
in like September,
August or September of 2015 and I was kind of at peak engagement at the time in
terms of work,
like I was on four shows and I really only had a little bit of time off in 2016
and I realized if I didn't make the movie in this one single week in,
in May of 2016 that I wasn't gonna be able to make it at all in,
in that year and I have to push to the next year.
And so then it just became about hitting that target,
like how can I hit this target?
So I never even went like the traditional way of trying to find like people to
finance the movie in a studio because they were going to say like,
we don't know,
this actor is like,
he's an unknown.
Can we put somebody famous in this role?
Can it be Ryan Gosling?
And then can it not be with Pete,
just him on camera?
Can we have other actors in the movie?
And then can we,
can we make it not in a car?
Can we make it,
I mean,
like we're just going to,
you know,
the whole kind of concept of the film was going to unravel.
You know,
it's very typical in Hollywood
where people are so risk averse that they take all of the edge and,
and um,
and like singularity at our project.
So very quickly I realized that I was going to have to probably crowd fund the
movie if I want it to do it my way and on my time,
on my timeframe.
So,
uh,
in about,
in,
in March of 2016,
I had my like first exploratory conversation with like the people around me and
with Kickstarter,
I wa I was able to,
you know,
they have people over there who are kind of like around to like help you kind of
figure out how to put a project together.
I built the campaign in three weeks.
I launched it in April.
And one of the rules about crowdfunding and Kickstarter specifically,
it's not hard and fast rule.
It's not like can rules that they enforce,
but it's just like a rule of thumb that if you raise half of your money in the
first week,
you'll probably fun fully.
So we had raised half of our money in that first week and then I started hiring
people,
uh,
on the film.
Um,
and we rea,
we did raise a lot of money for a feature.
It was about $200,000 that we raised.
And so that was what we had to make the movie.
Um,
and so originally it was,
we were going to make it nine days,
but I realized if I made it faster,
I'd have more money available to me.
Like daily,
I'd have to like,
my daily resource load would be higher.
So we cut the scheduled from nine days to seven days,
which is incredibly aggressive for a feature.
Whenever I tell people I made it in seven days,
they ask,
well how is it a short?
But,
um,
so we had to be really aggressive.
So everything we know,
we ended up doing it in this way that was so terrifying and so breakneck but so
exhilarating,
which is that we shot the first 15 pages of the movie in the first day and then
we shot that next 65 pages of the movie.
It was actually,
you said about 17 pages on the first date,
about six 67 pages on day two through seven.
Uh,
and that meant that the actor had to do 67 pages of dialogue day.
for people that don't know,
typically on a movie you do like between three and six pages of dialogue a day.
So he was essentially doing the entire movie all the way through every day,
locked in a hot car with no air conditioning in,
in,
in May,
the beginning of June,
essentially in Los Angeles.
Uh,
and it was just so intense,
but we shot three cameras.
So by day three,
we essentially had the entire movie in the can because,
you know,
we were doing the whole thing all the way through from three angles.
So my day to be at six and goals and we had the whole movie on,
on,
uh,
you know,
not on wax,
on the digital version of wax.
And so then the next four days we're just about kind of creative play.
And,
and I think that what the result is,
is this,
I made a movie in a week.
Um,
it's experimental.
It's unusual.
It,
it's transporting and strange and going in,
I thought,
I'll never make a movie this way again,
but now I would make a movie that way again because,
um,
I just didn't have any time to,
to
be afraid or feel down.
I just,
there was no time to be,
to,
to be anxious.
I just had to go.
It was really,
it was,
it was wonderful.
It was,
it was this like one of the seminal experiences
because of my life.
There's definitely some magic in the ether when you have a hyper aggressive
deadline,
there's just something that happens to the space time continuum and what you can
achieve.
Yeah.
When everything gets compressed that intensely.
Yes.
Certain things just come to the surface like it.
Certain things I've thrown into relief and it's not like you can't make
mistakes,
but I think you get a clarity sometimes because you can't dither.
Right.
You can't.
There's,
there is no time for paralysis by analysis.
I am making this decision.
I'm making it definitively.
It may be the wrong one,
but I'm going to lean all the way into it and we're going to see what happens
and also because we shot the whole movie all the way through.
If I,
if there were errors I had the next day to recalibrate in a way that you don't
get when you typically make a movie for people again who don't know,
like on a like on it,
you know,
I'm an actor as well.
So like when I'm on a TV show or I'm doing a movie or whatever,
I'll leave at the end of the day and go,
Oh shit man,
I wish I'd done this with that scene.
I wish I tried this.
But every day,
the next day we got to wake up and go,
you know what?
We have a whole new bite at this apple.
We're going to do it a whole different way today.
Um,
and so at the end I really felt like we,
we really fully explored the material which would not have,
we wouldn't have been able to do if we had making movie in seven days and not
doing it like with this kind of volume approach that we had.
So I'm looking at text in a book that you contributed to,
happens to be this,
this,
this.
I've tried to mend this fantastic book.
Oh,
let me see here it is for the,
for those of you who get the,
for the,
what about Bob Reference,
there's this groundbreaking new book.
Oh yes,
here it is.
And there's an entire shelf of the therapist's own bucket.
Uh,
Richard Dreyfus.
In any case,
the,
the question to what you would put on a gigantic billboard,
metaphorically speaking to get a message to millions or billions of people.
In this case what you selected was a Jack Canfield quote.
Everything you want is on the other side of fear and many of the stories that
you've told so far illustrate that.
Certainly.
What are you afraid of now?
Or what fear are you hoping say in the next year to get on the other side of,
does anything come to mind?
That's a good question.
Well,
you know,
it's interesting cause like I think like the one that feels the most obvious,
it's like I'm afraid I won't get to make another film,
but I,
I,
I'm not really legitimately afraid of that because I feel like I'm just going to
put this next movie together and make it like,
you know what?
Like I didn't know that I've done one like no help and no assistance from
anybody.
Like the next one's going to be cake.
Um,
I mean I had help.
I had my team,
but I didn't have the kind of traditional Hollywood help or I'd like a team of
agents kind of,
you know,
making magic.
Like it was really just like a scrappy little group of filmmakers,
you know,
doing this film would meet the,
the lead actor and screenwriter and,
and uh,
and,
and my creative executives.
It was a small group of people,
you know,
outside,
completely outside of the system.
Um,
but what am I afraid of?
God,
that's a really good,
and that it's not that I'm fearless,
it,
it may just be that the things that are interesting to me now don't engender
fear the way that they used to.
I can also,
I think tackle this from a different angle,
which is what do you currently,
what is one of your greatest struggles right now?
What do you struggle with?
Uh,
if,
uh,
if anything,
you know,
I,
my main struggle is just always a being as effective as I want to be.
You know what I mean?
I'm just super ambitious.
I have like highly developed.
I don't mean like I'm good at it.
I mean like,
it's like very far advanced.
Uh,
like workaholism I mean like,
like I have pathological,
we're calling them.
It's,
it's like a sickness.
And when I tell,
whenever I say I'm workaholic,
people always laugh and I go look,
look at it.
Like it's a problem,
you know?
I don't know how to rest.
Um,
I don't,
it's not that I don't like to play.
I do like play,
but,
um,
like I don't think I have any time to,
to rest I and,
and I worry that it makes me,
it,
it could result in me not being an interesting artists because I think you need
to play into daydream and to rest and to experience things,
to be able to tell interesting stories.
You know,
no one wants to hear about,
you know,
your daily trek from your home to your office.
It's just not compelling.
I remember,
you know,
I think it was Amanda Palmer said this,
I apologize to ever set it if a misattributing uh,
but the,
the Amanda Palmer creative musician extraordinaire and she said,
you don't,
God,
I think it was her who said in order to ha she married to Neil Gaiman.
She is,
yeah.
All the time.
Okay.
Yeah,
exactly.
For those of you who are you and after me,
yeah.
Yeah.
I will.
I will bow at the feet of Neil,
came in as a writer and everybody should listen to his audio book of the
Graveyard Book narrated by him.
He is also the most soothing voice imaginable.
But I digress.
Uh,
what the fuck was I saying?
Amanda Palmer has a quote.
Ah,
yes.
That,
uh,
either if,
if life,
uh,
if,
if art imitates life,
in order to create art,
you have to have a life,
right?
Yeah.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And,
and like,
and I'm paraphrasing,
it's butchered.
It makes the point that you can't,
you know,
I'm sure there are other theories.
There's,
I,
there's a very famous French writer.
It's not sounds but sits.
It's,
uh,
it's somebody anyway about like have bourgeois leaf and be real
life and be radical in your work.
But I actually don't think I,
I,
and I actually think that you,
you need to be fully engaged in your life in order to be an interesting artist.
Um,
because you know,
you need to be alive to be able to speak about the human condition.
So if you've had,
if you have advanced early onset workoholism,
right.
You've,
you've really turned this into a default mode.
What are you doing anything to,
to try and manage that or create more slack in the system for the daydreaming
and so on?
I mean,
it's like,
that's my daily practice.
That's my life.
That's my one day at a time.
Like just constantly trying to remind myself to rest.
Um,
I,
I engage socially a lot more than I used to.
Uh,
my social,
you mean out in the real world?
The real world.
I can go out and I,
and I,
you know,
I try to not just be like,
I just had a period of life where I was just like up Jim,
work,
sleep,
you know,
and just,
I just remember one day I was like,
I'm going to die.
Like the,
I'm going to,
I'm going to die of boredom.
I bore myself,
you know what I mean?
And so,
you know,
like I,
I think I try to court danger in a safe way.
It's not like I'm jumping on a plane with no parachute or bull fighting or you
know,
bare knuckle brawling in an alley,
you know,
filled with needles.
But I,
but I am trying to dislike B,
B.
Not always have my head in my computer,
but,
but look,
the reason that people are workaholics,
well,
there's lots of reasons I'm sure social presses,
but for me,
I just get this big like serotonin release as a Serotonin was the brain.
What's the satisfaction drug up dopamine,
perhaps dopamine,
Serotonin,
sleepy,
sleepy time.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean,
I get a dopamine release when I,
when I complete tasks and I just,
you know,
I get,
I get higher and higher.
The more that I execute,
I find executing in and of itself really enjoyable.
So I'm just trying to apply that aggression to like,
like leisure.
Like can I get the same satisfaction from it?
If I,
if I,
if I make it to do list and one of the things is have fun,
well,
I get the same dopamine release.
If I had a lot of fun,
um,
how can I turn fun into work most effectively?
Then I'd be like,
ah,
I don't know about you guys,
but I just fucking crushed my to do list.
You know?
I,
uh,
I realized that like,
I,
even though I can feel very harried,
it's interesting to me to be feeling like a part of being on this planet to like
fully engaging and doing everything I can do and everything I'm interested in
and am because I don't want to look back and be like,
man,
I should have tried that.
I'm happy to look back and say,
man,
I tried that and it went terribly for me.
That's a,
that's a perfectly comfortable space for me to be like,
man,
I tried that and I completely shit the bed.
But,
but what,
what I find very uncomfortable is the idea that I always wanted to do something
and I never did it.
And so that's what I fear.
What I fear is what I fear is not,
is not trying,
not experiencing all the things that I want to experience.
How do you think you get some money?
Yeah.
How do you think your life,
because you,
you have,
you live so aggressively,
you milk the most out of the hours that you have.
How would you or your life be different if you didn't have exercise as an
element do you think?
Well,
it's interesting because I really,
I really love working out,
uh,
but there's a constant battle for me between like being effective,
like with work and like,
you know,
I,
I'm,
I'm the queen of like getting up at like 5:00 AM to work out putting on my
workout clothes and them being in front of my computer at four o'clock in the
afternoon and I haven't moved.
Like,
I mean,
that's just like my,
as just a normal day.
Like didn't,
didn't move,
didn't eat and do anything,
just been in front of the computer for like 11 hours.
Um,
but it just,
it's just such a great stress manager.
And I also think that there's another thing there,
which is it just,
again,
like puts you back in your body,
you know,
this like thing that's carrying your brain around and making you effective.
And you know,
I'm,
I think that with everything that all of the stimulus that we stimuli that we
experienced nowadays,
all the pictures and the images of perfection that are coming in at a much
faster and more voluminous pace,
it's really easy to fall into like a,
like an abusive relationship with,
with exercise,
either doing it so much that you know,
you're hurting yourself or not doing it.
And then the engaging that inner monologue about how you're like,
you're worthless and you can't get your shit together.
And I don't have either of those things.
I just know I'm happier and better when I work out a,
but I don't,
I don't,
I don't do,
I've finally dropped the monologue about like,
you know,
I'm like,
no,
I'm not.
I'm not a good person if I don't like,
I've,
I don't crush your workout.
I just try to do it every day because I know what I'm better mentally.
And I also cheat completely.
Like I have my five hot,
took a hike today,
you know,
I had my phone with me and like,
I stopped every 10 minutes.
Like,
write something down,
you know,
I'm not really like fully and I'm not being in the moment when I'm working out.
A lot of times I'm stopping like in the hundreds of times to make notes and
remind myself of stuff I have to do or put stuff on my calendar.
Do you still use a concept too
or rowing machine?
I still use my grandmother or my constituted commoner.
I have had it since 2000.
It is 18 years old.
I have never had to repair it or replace any parts.
Uh,
it's,
uh,
it's the best.
It's the single best piece of equipment that I have my whole gym now I have my
whole gym.
I'm in my place.
I have a TRX bodyweight system.
I have two kettle bells at 25 and 35.
I have my org arbiter.
I have battle ropes that are attached to my dining room table.
And I have one big power step that I just used to do like pistols and stuff like
that.
And I get everything done with five things.
That is fantastic.
So pistols for villa donor,
those are one legged squats.
Uh,
and uh,
they can be very,
very difficult,
uh,
dependent depending on how you go about it or a step can help you because it
could just kind of do like single leg step downs until you build up your,
your quad and your glute strength to do pistols.
What could you describe for us a recent workout or what a prototypical work out
of yours might look like?
Um,
well I,
I hike today that was just like a 90 minute hike,
which is this more about like feeling groovy.
But,
um,
right now I'm obsessed with my urometer.
Uh,
I like,
I kind of go through periods of like mount rowing and then periods of rowing
really aggressively.
And uh,
this is,
this is gonna be right up your alley,
Tim.
I'm ready.
This is like center,
this is like Bullseye for you and your audience.
I started going to a naturopath so I'd be like supplementing differently and I
started taking good if I on and I'm rowing like faster now than I did in my
twenties.
Like I just keep getting personal bests on it,
bro.
It's confusing.
I'm,
I'm a lot older than I am,
a lot older than I was when I was running competitively.
And I just keep like knocking like 30 seconds and then 45 seconds and then a
minute and 10 seconds off my rowing times.
So now I'm just obsessed with by kidding,
personal best every time I row.
Okay.
Let's dig into this.
So the Glutathione,
uh,
how is it for those who aren't familiar glutosiome is thought of a simple way to
think of it or the way it's often described as,
as a a master antioxidant of sorts.
Uh,
how are you having administered?
Is it being in that,
oh,
this is so inside baseball sometimes I get Ivs,
I get ivs if I really like,
if I'm a wreck,
it's like if I travel a lot or I went to Coachella.
And is that,
is that pure,
is that,
is that just gludethyon or are you doing that at the B vitamins?
I can do at the end of my IB,
I'll get like B vitamins and glutathione push at the end.
But you can get,
you can get like fat soluble can get this like fat soluble good Osi on that.
You just take a,
you just like gulped down
like axle grease.
Yeah,
I
is this,
what is this company a lipid?
It's lipid spheric.
That's the name.
Like the spirit.
Yeah.
I remember getting into the glutathione because before the glue of the fine,
I was running slow and now I'm just like a Jack Rabbit so it could be something
else,
but I'm going to,
I'm going to say it's the good if I on,
I will warn people in advance.
I had some of this life life spheric Ethan at one point and I gave it to a
friend of mine and I think it might've been for those who know my buddy Kevin
Rose since I like to mention him even miss attribute things to him just for fun.
Um,
I think I gave him one and he said something like,
what is this horse semen?
It does have a weird,
very weird consistency and Tara,
no,
my father calls it axle grease.
That's what he's like,
give me this axle grease because I gave it to my dad.
I was like,
I think this would really help you and you're supposed to take it and liquid.
But he's just been eating on a spoon and he's up.
He's up.
He's a better man than I.
Oh,
I just like squeegee it out of the little packet into your mouth to mouth.
I take it,
I take it with like about to like two ounces of Kombucha and the morning so I
don't have to think about it,
but he'll like,
I've take soap.
I mean you're,
I'm sure you're like this or maybe you,
maybe after all of that experimentation on yourself,
you just get up and have a bowl,
like frosted flakes in the morning.
10.
But you know,
it's like I do that.
I'm,
I have my bowl of supplements so that I have my fish oil and then I have my
curcumin and then I haven't my turmeric like by the end of the morning,
like I,
I've just,
I've supplemented that.
It's like a banquet.
Like I don't even need to eat.
I've taken so many crappy tablets
just to just hit pause again.
So you is the exercise before breakfast,
is it the first thing you do?
What is your first ideal morning?
What's the first 90 minutes?
60 to 90 minutes of like,
um,
uh,
a special shot glutathione.
What time?
What time do you wake up?
It depends on the day.
Like,
you know,
between like six and seven.
Okay.
I just pick up a lot earlier,
but I let one of my shows go so I don't have to wake up at the crack of dawn
every day anymore.
So it's like between like six and seven o'clock and then work out in the morning
or I won't get,
I won't,
I won't wake up.
You have espresso shot glutosiome with always have coffee before I work out,
like without fail.
And then the glue to phone with the Kombucha.
Any particular type of Kombucha that's your preferred axle?
Grease mixer.
I like better booch um,
and I like,
was it life fade I think is one of the other,
I love Kombucha.
I'm just,
I'm,
I'm very,
I'm s I'm very slutty when it comes to come put y'all drink.
They come.
It's a fan.
All right.
So then,
then you,
then you buckled down to workout.
And this is going to sound like,
I'm just looking for opportunities to plug,
which maybe I am,
but the,
you described your,
your work,
the one of your workouts,
the concept to like mid distance five k rose punctuated by short distance,
two k hit sprints,
high intensity interval training or high intensity interval training with,
with a 10 kid long distance rail once or twice a week.
Is that,
would that be the current workout?
That's typically my workouts.
And then I'll do like,
I'll do like,
like a set of five,
five by 25 kettle bells.
Sounds like,
you know,
like I'll get up one morning,
just do 125 kettlebell swings in front of the television and then sometimes I'll
do a TRX workout.
Uh,
because I didn't have really a way to stimulate pull ups.
So that was like,
that was why I got the CRX,
so I could do that.
Was like the one thing I didn't have and here was a pull up bar.
Is The TRX attached to it to a door?
Is it a,
that's like a railing,
like I have like a,
like a,
an upstairs railing and it just hangs off of the railing.
Got It.
And,
and,
and that's it.
I mean,
I tried,
I tried to keep it like relatively simple so then I'll do it.
Um,
I don't really train with anybody because I just can't,
I can't,
I can manage the hour workout,
but I can't manage the,
the transit between up mice home and ups.
I don't have enough time to do that too.
You know what I mean?
Like I've got the hour,
I don't have two hours,
so I just,
I don't go to a gym anymore because I just,
I just would be,
I wouldn't have the time for it.
Um,
the transit time,
transit time was what killed me and I was like,
I have an hour to work out,
but I don't have an half hour on either side of that to,
to go,
go to the gym.
Do you still watch shows when you row?
Totally.
Any recent favorites or what are you watching currently?
Just like fantastic junk.
Uh,
I mean some good stuff.
Like I love,
I watched the walking dead fear,
the walking dead.
That's what he's really good workout shows right now I'm watching the magicians,
um,
during my workouts and then when I finished that,
what will I watch after that?
Sometimes I watch stuff that's on streaming services cause I hate to have to,
when I'm growing,
I don't want to have to watch commercials and I can't stop to fast forward
because I'm trying to beat my previous road time.
So,
uh,
like I'll stream the extreme stuff on Hulu,
like a x files or Handmaid's tale or I just watched a show called Deutschland
83.
That was pretty great.
Um,
it has to be something that I can kind of watch,
which is why I'll typically watch something that's like not too mentally
demanding.
Uh,
you know,
so I don't,
I,
I can't,
I can't pay attention too closely to plot points.
Uh,
do you make New Year's resolutions?
Do you have any routines or rituals around New Year's worth?
We're talking just for people who may be listening to this at another time.
We're chatting at the end of March,
like any this year.
Right?
I make the same one every year,
which is to rest more.
I mean,
it's the same resolution every arrest.
So how are you going to do that this time?
I don't know.
I should just give up.
I should stop making resolutions and then I won't have to have not have not,
I mean look,
maybe,
maybe a part of success or like,
like success at being you like figuring out,
being you,
it's like understanding what your strengths and your weaknesses are.
You know,
like my strength is,
my strength is,
is my aggressive work ethic.
And,
um,
it was when I like when I was a young comic,
I would be like,
oh,
I should be writing every day.
I should write.
It should be like this guy.
Well,
like that's just not my,
that's just not how I operate.
So I think once you accept like what your own methodology of this is why this is
why you watched the Terminator 30 Times like this,
this is my people,
right?
I mean I have definitely have a CDM,
definitely a personality,
but like once you accept like this is mice,
how these are my strengths,
this is where I excel,
this is how I excel.
Rather than try to force yourself into someone else's like workflow,
like figure out what yours is.
I as a writer and you've written lots of books.
I've only written two,
but with both books I had this huge lead time and it wasn't that I was lazy or
procrastinate and like the book wasn't there yet.
And then just one day the book was there and then I sat down and I wrote the
entire book in a few weeks,
but it just needed to Gel.
It needed to synthesize.
And if I had been trying to sit down and kind of write a little bit every day,
it would have just been like this,
like big agglomeration of glop.
But just one day I was like,
Oh,
the book is in,
the book is in me now the book has in me.
And then I got it out,
you know?
Oh God,
I wish that,
I wish I had that experience,
man of so jelly.
Oh,
but everybody's different.
Like a long time.
I would have wanted to be more like you like disciplined and sitting down and
because you know there's,
there's a,
there's a panic that didn't suit you when you are seven weeks when your deadline
and you had nine months to write a book.
And Yeah.
But it's just like that for me,
certain threads have to connect and that requires like rumination and,
and time and,
and you know,
I,
I can't just can't do it any other way.
So I don't,
I think,
I think my strength is eating every day,
trying to eat a wheelbarrow full of glass and shit out diamonds or something
like that.
That should be a tattoo.
Uh,
well,
speaking of eating glass,
uh,
so what this is this,
this may might be predictable,
but I'm okay with predictable.
I would like to start to wrap up with a handful of questions.
And the first one I'm going to ask is,
and you actually give people a head a heads up on this with the self inflicted
wounds.
So,
uh,
usually say at some point I'm going to ask you about x,
but I'm,
I'm sure you've had time to think about this.
So do you have any favorite stories of self inflicted wounds of your own that
you could,
that you could share?
I mean,
obviously the book is just a collection,
not even a comprehensive one,
but,
but quite detailed of many,
many mistakes that I've made.
Um,
I'm trying to think of something that's happened recently.
It's,
it's interesting.
I see my mistakes differently now than I did when I was younger.
They just feel like an aspect of being human versus like some kind of tragic,
uh,
why exactly.
They just see it just seemed like an unavoidable aspect of being alive.
Um,
and I'm trying to think if there's,
if there's one like,
and then I'm thinking of ones that recently that don't feel like that,
that cataclysmic.
So they're like,
they're like lame,
lame stories.
Oh,
you could pick a classic,
uh,
also like the,
the,
the greatest hits.
Like if you're watching TV 15 years ago and it's like hits from the 80s,
we could,
we could take one of those as well.
Okay.
Of that.
Um,
Oh God,
uh,
think of it.
I think Megan,
Megan,
we're going to go anyway.
It's interesting.
Like I was talking about that short film that I made,
uh,
that,
um,
uh,
that was like the one that will never be seen by any human being.
I actually,
I think it's been destroyed where it was just like,
I just thought that I could just charm my way to this short.
And I had a bunch of friends kind of show up and it was such an odd,
it was such an odd idea.
I didn't even make any sense.
It was about a guy who flashed women,
uh,
and um,
he flashed women and I can't remember why he flashed women,
but it was to do with like bravery.
Uh,
it was like a metaphor for bravery that the sky would like flash women and,
and also maybe like,
like Hubris,
like the idea that like people are going to be super excited to see this guy's
penis and he would kind of like try to use it as currency and it would never
kind of go his way,
but it just made no sense.
It just ended up being like a series of vignettes about a guy like reeling his
penis straight.
Harris.
I just remember at the end,
like literally thinking it's one thing to think like people don't get me.
I was like,
I don't get myself,
I
accomplish here.
Um,
and it was,
it,
it just never ever coalesced.
But,
but it was,
it was fine because it was like,
I remember kind of enjoying the process of making it and then being really kind
of surprised and delighted by what a piece of shit.
It was a much like that set where nobody laughed.
I thought,
well man,
that didn't work at all.
Okay,
I need to go back and figure out what to do next.
And I think like,
I think every artist,
you know,
I think Quentin Tarantino is a famous story about his first film being
unwatchable,
you know?
Um,
I think,
I just think,
you know,
sometimes if,
if your personality is to be really aggressive and kind of dive in,
you're bound,
you're bound to make some spectacular failures,
you know,
and,
and you just have to have a high tolerance for that and,
and not take it personally and keep moving forward.
But yeah,
I literally was like,
I know you guys don't get it.
I don't get it.
I don't know.
I can't explain it to you if I have no idea what I was thinking.
Thank you for putting yourselves in my hands.
It was a terrible mistake.
On your part,
but you're very gracious to have trusting me with your lives.
What does,
what's the name of the short,
it was called the Wipper
all sorts of images and it makes no sense whatsoever.
When have you been extremely proud of yourself?
Could be any point in your life.
Can you,
can you think of standout point where you're like,
God damn like,
good for me.
Fucking I hate,
I hate to have it be about this because it sounds like it's super self
promotional,
but I really am proud of this film and I,
for a variety of reasons,
I think because it,
it didn't,
it did was yeah.
Access because it was such a,
um,
I mean I was lucky that I was brought a great script and I add a really talented
actor,
but we put this movie together like so quickly.
Um,
and I knew and I had a vision for it,
but I also was,
because we were moving so fast to feeling my way,
it's too dark in some aspect.
And I think one of the reasons why it,
it came together the way that it did was because I was,
I was both,
I both had a vision for the film,
but I was open to modulating.
And I think that's really important in anything that you're doing,
no matter what field you're in,
is that you have to both we prize vision and kind of rigidity and in this
culture.
But I think that being able to pivot and be nimble is way more important than
being kind of a rigid visionary.
Um,
you have to be able to look at data and interpreted and then apply it to your
situation.
Or are you just,
you're just to keep banging your head against
the wall.
So,
you know,
we,
we made this movie,
we got into the very first,
second day of filming.
We,
we started really late.
We lost our light.
We had to kind of pivot that day.
I ended up having to throw all that footage away.
Um,
another day we lost light and had to get back up at five in the morning,
kind of shoot don for dust.
But we just kept pivoting.
We just kept,
nothing was catastrophic.
Okay.
Like,
and I think that's something I got from my father.
It's like,
okay,
this isn't working.
Okay,
so we're going to do this.
that's not working.
We're going to do this.
Rather than,
Oh my God,
this is the end of the world.
What are we going to do?
Um,
and then in post I had very little money for post and very little time to cut
the movie together and about four weeks in the editor that I had cutting,
there'll be,
who was a great guy,
really talented,
just wasn't connecting with the material.
It wasn't,
wasn't able to assemble the movie.
It was an unusual movie.
It's one guy in a car and I had to let him go and then I had to learn avid,
the avid system and start cutting the movie myself.
Uh,
but again,
I wasn't like,
what I'm going to do,
I don't have an editor.
I'm going to die.
Just said,
okay,
well like the,
the answer here is that I'm going to learn this skill set and I'm going to keep
moving forward.
Um,
and then,
you know,
I made this little film that was seen as strange and atmospheric and dreamlike
and you know,
it didn't get into Sundance and everybody always wants to get into Sundance,
but then it got into eight other festivals and won two awards and got picked up
for distribution.
And the result has been much better than I ever could have anticipated.
Uh,
and,
and um,
I'm really proud of it because I mean,
I made,
made it for what is typically the catering budget,
autumn on a regular,
a Hollywood movie.
You know what I mean?
It,
we made it for just no money and in no time.
And,
um,
and I think it also says something.
I think what I'm also proud of is that the movie actually does have a strong
point of view and a strong visual personality and a strong style that is my own.
When I look at it,
I don't think I'm trying to emulate anybody.
I feel like this is,
this is something that I made.
It's my,
it's my little lumpy ashtray from shop class and,
and I,
I really love it.
Good for you.
And it's
there.
There's this,
I think it's easy to not not,
I'm not saying you,
but for humans to look at.
The people who were showcased on the covers of magazines are on the front pages
of popular websites and think,
wow,
they figured out all the secret sauce,
or they have the keys to the kingdom and they're able to show up and just hit
home runs every time they step to the plate.
And when you look at the origin stories of some of these incredible creations
that people are familiar with,
whether it's a jaws or the company,
Alibaba is one example.
Jack Ma,
the founder,
I think he's the richest man in China or certainly one of the top few at this
point.
And he said,
I'm paraphrasing,
but we had a huge advantage in the beginning and that was we had no
experience,
no money and no plan.
And it forces you to really think outside of the box.
And even if that project doesn't succeed by outside measures,
the confidence that you develop in exploring areas outside of the box can then
transfer to future projects.
I remember there was this fantastic documentary,
I'm going to butcher his name.
It will,
it's fantastic.
Mostly for the message,
not for all of the content,
which I hope makes sense,
but it's called a Yoda worst skis doing.
And it's the story of this attempt to make a movie about Dune.
And the thing is a complete unmitigated disaster,
like complete under the disaster.
But the,
the,
the talent that was assembled went on to just do incredible things.
And if that disaster hadn't happened,
one could argue that if you,
if you'd stepped on that butterfly,
these other careers wouldn't have lost him in the way that they did and you
wouldn't have the Geiger design of the alien that people now know as the Elliot
of Aliens and so on.
So it's a,
I just love,
yeah.
This,
that no one ever learns from success.
I mean,
you,
you can kind of,
you can kind of do a postmortem and say,
oh,
this stuff works.
But failure is where it is,
where you have explosive growth,
where you really have to reconsider all of your assumptions.
And,
uh,
and it's,
it's so much more powerful than success is at making you eventually successful.
Um,
so yeah,
the aggressive,
the aggressive a,
G,
G R E s S.
Ivy.
Oh,
totally.
Yes.
I,
that's,
that's my life philosophy.
Be Aggressive,
be aggressive.
And uh,
we want you around for a long time.
So take your cat naps at the very least.
That's my goal.
And I do you have anything you would like to say or ask of the audience
suggestions you'd like to make?
Anything at all that you'd like to,
to say before we wrap up?
Other than watch my movie.
How other than watch your movies.
Exactly.
Um,
that's interesting.
I mean,
I,
I guess like,
I like when I,
when I did my podcast,
you know,
like it somatically,
the stuff that we've talked about was always stuff that I talked about,
which is like,
it doesn't matter what your,
what you want to do,
like,
you know,
and again,
it sounds very greeting card,
but like the barriers are,
they're imagined,
you know what I mean?
And,
and,
and it may be you're going to have to start small and maybe we're going to have
to start,
uh,
close to home.
But like the,
the,
the greater regret will always be not having started.
And,
uh,
this,
it's,
I'm always trying to find a way to be more bold in my life and hopefully share
the things that have helped me do that with other people.
So it is exciting to be having the conversation with you because I think that's
a lot of what you've done is you've kind of,
you know,
live these experiences so that the things that you learned could be shared with
other people.
Uh,
and it's,
you know,
just go out and do awesome shit.
Get your hands dirty,
dirty,
rough drafts are not a clean business.
Absolutely not.
Thank you so much for taking the time.
And it was a pleasure.
So much fun.
So I know it's Super Fun and now that I know where you are,
I will track you down the next time I'm in your neck of the woods,
barbecue music,
whatever it might be and in Austin Tay Hos come visit and people can visit you
is theBest@thissiteiusedtotyler.com you know who spends time on a website
anymore.
Just follow me.
Follow me on Twitter,
Facebook,
Instagram,
all that stuff is just Ayesha Tyler,
one word I s h a t.
Y.
L.
E r.
Absolutely.
And everyone,
I'm sorry you were going to say something.
It's just kind of,
I don't know if this is going to post,
but uh,
I post stuff about all this stuff I'm doing,
um,
the movies out on the 10th of April on video,
on demand,
iTunes,
all that stuff.
And then archer starts I think on the 24th of April and all the others,
I don't know,
TV,
whatever.
You can find me online.
I don't know when you're going to listen to this,
but you know,
just come say hi to me on.
I'm on Social Center for days and weeks and months and years and millennia to
come.
Hopefully cockroaches will be listening to this on a tiny units on the rest of
us are dead.
That's exactly right.
Cockroaches.
Remember us fondly and for you non cockroach is actually have cockroaches
listening.
You're welcome also to check out the show notes where I will provide links to
everything that we've talked about including access and you can find all of
those at tim.blog/podcast along with the show notes for every other episode and
I should thank you so much.
One more time for being so goddamn entertaining and inspiring at the same time.
It's a rear combo,
so really appreciate it.
Great to talk with you.
Thanks Tim.
Of course.
And to everybody out there on the interwebs,
uh,
be safe.
Maybe a more important,
be aggressive.
Get out there if you've,
if you're dreaming of doing something,
creating something some day,
just get out a shitty first draft because guess what?
All the first drafts are really fucking awful.
It's very rare that someone just,
as I was alluding to,
Shit's out diamonds,
uh,
on a,
on a daily basis.
It's,
it starts with putting something out there into the world and uh,
hopefully at least it makes a market of one happy and that is you.
So I will close there and
thanks to everybody for listening.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends.
For instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend,
so if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you will get the very next one and if you
sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by legal zoom,
which more than 2 million Americans have used to help start their businesses.
Past guests even such as well,
wordpress lead developer,
CEO of Automattic,
Matt Mullenweg now valued at more than a billion dollars,
have used legal zoom to help with their business needs.
Specifically in his case to form has company butts.
Legal Zoom isn't just for launching your business.
There are services include everything from helping you to manage changing tax
laws,
doing contract screening,
Ndas,
nondisclosure agreements,
important stuff,
handling lease agreements and assisting with really any other legal challenge,
hurdle inconvenienced that typically takes time and effort away from running
your business.
The best part is that you won't get charged by the hour because legal zoom isn't
a law firm,
so they won't be running the clock up and spinning circles just to raise your
bill.
Instead,
they just ask you to pay one low upfront price for whatever it is that you're
looking to get all the card style,
so visit legal zoom.com and check out their business section for all of their
services and if you want special savings,
that's the terminology in the coffee that they suggest.
I don't know what the special savings is folks,
but it's titillating.
If you want special savings,
enter Promo Code Tim Tim at checkout capital t,
lowercase.
I am again,
take a peek legal zoom.com and enter Promo code.
Tim,
this episode is brought to you by teeter.
I am so thrilled to have connected with these guys because I've used teeter
products for many,
many years.
I've traveled around the country and the world with teeter products and I'm
sitting about 15 feet in my home from one of their inversion tables and we're
going to talk more about all of that.
One of my rituals is hanging and I should say not really that it's a maintenance
and performance program.
I hang not just in the morning potentially,
but particularly after a day of bearing weight,
whether that includes weight training in Jersey,
Greg Rec world record holder insists on this type of inversion therapy after
training or just wearing heavy backpack around a few minutes goes a long way
towards better sleep.
In my case,
less back pain,
neck pain,
leg pain.
It's not a panacea obviously,
but inversion therapy would use gravity and your own body weight,
decompress the spine of the pressure on the discs and surrounding nerves seems
to help with a whole slew of conditions and just as a general maintenance
program,
it's one of my favorite things to do.
So what to say about that teeter?
Why teeter teeter is the best known name in inversion table since 1981 more than
3 million people have put their trust in teeter teeters.
Also the only inversion table brand that has been both safety certified by
underwriters laboratories as the UL for the people in that industry.
You will recognize it and register with the FDA as a class one medical device
and they're giving a very special offer just to you guys,
my listeners.
For a limited time you can get the teeter inversion table with bonus
accessories,
which I have a bunch of again in the room next to me and a free pair of gravity
boots so that you can invert at home or take the boots with you to the gym.
So these gravity boots,
I have three separate pairs of gravity boots bought with my own monies in three
different cities that I've had for a very,
very long time because I don't want to travel with them necessarily.
It looked kind of like ski boots but without the foot portion and they hook you
upside down so you can take them and really anywhere you want to go to get this
deal,
which is a savings of over $148 it's very specific.
So maybe it's 149 you have to go to twitter.com forward slash Tim,
that's teeter.com full touched him.
T.
E.
R.
Y'all see a free shipping,
a 60 day money back guarantee and free returns.
So why not try to remember it.
You can only get the teeter inversion table with bonus accessories and a free
pair of gravity boots by going to [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim.
So if you're thinking to yourself,
what the hell is this thing he's talking about?
I can't even envision it in my head.
Well,
take a look at the photos.
Go to teeter.com forward slash 10.